[Music]
[Music]
for um
the best chess players in the world
remain in the skilling open as we head
into semi-finals today
now who can avoid the biggest time
trouble and
the most devastating blunders as nerves
get higher
well welcome to the champions chess tour
welcome to my humble abode
this time i'll be playing from moscow
but here's where i live
hi this is there are time differences so
i have to change my sleep schedule
accordingly this one usually works for
power so this is my desk
we need a very good mouth there's the
old mouse i use for all the other
tournaments
it can be a little bit dark in here some
of the medals
i love online chess because i can play
from the comfort of my home having
indian food
lots of lots of stuff for winning the
skilling open is not enough
i need some more
the scaling open is the very first
tournament in the champions chess tour
we are done with preliminaries we're
done with quarterfinals
for players remain and to guide us
through the semi-finals uh women's
grandmaster ivanka houska
and grandmaster david howell and david
among these four
semi-finalists are there any surprises i
think there might well be surprises on
the cards these are the four
best online speed players in the whole
world yes we have magnus carlsen the
world champion yes we have hikaru
nakamura the king of online chess
but their opponents today are extremely
good as well and ivanka they have now
played
five days of intense chess what do you
expect from the semi-finals
well like you said it's been intense
there's been so
much drama on the board i fully expect
that to continue
and in fact the players themselves are
getting into the fighting mood in fact
magnus coulson the champ himself he
tweeted
so i guess that guy referring to aneesh
curry
isn't playing today
and anita was quick to respond with oh
he's already missing missing me so yes
on twitter there and you have to
remember that we do want
everyone to join in the fun and join in
the conversation and you can do this
by tweeting us by using the hashtag
chesschamps
send us your move suggestions your
tweets your comments anything goes
definitely and we definitely will miss
anish geary to a fantastic chess player
he did get knocked out in the
quarterfinals again against magnus
carlsen and we have
as we mentioned come to the semi-finals
ivanka that means two days
of uh two matches or what does this mean
i mean what is the structure for the
semi-finals it's gonna be fantastic
that's what it means kai
is gonna be so good we will have two
days of intense chess when the four
players
will play head-to-head matches those are
two matches and
each match consists of four rapid
games a day and and wrap it david
uh we've been through this many days now
we we know the time control but
yesterday we did see uh the tie breaks
in the quarter finals obviously this is
the first days
uh day of semi-finals and and what will
this day look like
that's right so today will just be a
maximum of four games we are going to
forget the blitz forget the armageddon
for now
the today will be uh four games 15
minutes for each side
per game they do get 10 seconds after
every move just one point for a win
half point for a draw but today is just
best of four best off for
okay so this is what we have in store
for today's
first day of semi-finals now the
quarterfinals were
decided yesterday magnus carlsen was the
big favorite
against anish geary but the world
champion got off to a
nervous start wesley so had a slow start
to the quarter-finals and
lost day one against timor rajabov but
he was able to take the match to tie
breaks both blitz games ended in draws
and with the black pieces so
only needed a draw in the armageddon i
think we've just seen a big blunder on
the board look at rajabov's face he just
looks shocked
black's queen is attacking a rook along
the diagonal and the other rook along
the other diagonal
white can't protect them both at the
same time this game is decided
i'm very pleased with uh with my play
today things went much better
to be honest with you i didn't expect to
make it today but he wasn't able to put
much pressure when he got the white
pieces
in the semi-finals he will face hikaru
nakamura who came back
strong on day two of the quarter-finals
against maxim vashir lagrave
karna kamura he beat washington the
american is back
it all came down to the thai breaks
where vashya lagrav
won the first blitz game and nakamura
once
again had to strike back it is game over
hikaru has done it
what a turnaround the american chose
black and the armageddon
and managed to get the draw he so needed
karnaka borah came back so strong today
he won
in the quarterfinal between levon
aronian and ian napomniachi we had a lot
of
action aronian won the first match but
nam pomniacci
had a great second day it's not the best
move it might be a bit of a mistake by
levon
he could have won instantly this
actually blows all of his advantage
it all came down to tie breaks when
apomniachi
snatched the semi-final ticket and
aronian
resigns it is checkmate next move his
king's defenseless
aneesh giri could have gained the upper
hand in game one against
rival magnus carson but instead of
pushing for the win
the dutchman played it to save don't
trade those queens initially because
if you trade those queens magnus carlsen
biggest endgame experts out there
oh no he's married he's traded the queen
off the board no
no then we see the bars zoom back
towards the center don't do this at home
kids don't trade queens when you
when you're on the attack were you
surprised when he offered to trade queen
sir
no i know how he plays it's a sort of
position where there it feels like there
should be something very very strong for
black but maybe it's not so easy to find
carlson won the first quarter final
match but on day two
geary once again had the chance to push
for a win
he has played it oh my god everything's
going to start leaving the board in a
minute and
anishikiri he's he's let him off the
hook again
and he knows he's let it slip but all
four games
ended in draws and carlson is ready for
the semi-finals where he will face
nepomniacci
he's a very strong player i think he
played very very well
today to make a massive comeback so
it's going to be tough all right well
david magnus carlsen is expecting
a tough semi-final isn't he that's right
it's going to be extremely tough i mean
that game
against anishigiri it was so tense so
close but janna pomniacci his rival
today in the semi-finals he's
he's the guy he's magnus carson's
kryptonite he's the one of the few who
has beaten magnus on several occasions
before
all right we will take a look at what
the quarter-finals ended up like and
the semi-finals that we will have in
store today so magnus carlsen the winner
in the game between him and unish geary
he will face jan
pomnyachi today who beat lavon ironian
in the quarter-finals wesley soh came
back
so strong yesterday he beat timor rajabo
in thai breaks
and he will face hikaru nakamura who
also
in thai breaks beats maxim bashir lagram
so
i guess we have to sort of expect ivanka
that both
the two americans come in with
self-confidence and even energy after
those tie breaks yesterday
absolutely they were both on the verge
of leaving the competition
when they came back they had a fantastic
day
and luck was on their side so we can
expect some hard-fought chess there
all right fantastic okay so we have four
of the very very very best
chess players in the world remaining in
the champions chester
the first tournament skilling open let's
get to know them a little bit better
hikaru nakamura the most obvious threat
to magnus carlsen's crown
he's the only player to best the champ
in any discipline
and the time controls played in the tour
suit his strengths
nakamura's secret is that he has a
finely tuned game plan for every match
something even carlson says he struggles
against and he has an army of fans
online
cheering him on jan napomniachi born in
the same year as magnus carlsen
the russian number one was ahead of the
reigning world champion of the youngster
nepomniacci is a class act with enormous
potential
wesley soh hit world number two in 2016
and was talked about as the next big
thing in chess
and a potential world champion in 2019
he crushed magnus carlsen to become the
fisher random world champion
and in 2020 he won a second u.s
championship
title magnus carlsen
the norwegian king of chess has been
called everything from
the young justin bieber of chess in his
younger years
to the mozart's of chess in more recent
years
now 30 he's a four-time world champion
who also holds the rapid and blitz
crowns
the record highest rating in history the
longest unbeaten streak in history
he has won everything carlson has to
fight for his reputation
in every game
so these are the four players in the
semifinals fighting for those
two spots in the skilling open final and
the first semifinal matchup we do have
is between hikaru nakamura and wesley so
an all-american battle david and what's
your expectations
that's right this one is going to go to
the wire we see there
in the graphics on the screen we see
their head-to-head scores
hikaru nakamura he's only beaten wesley
so once in classical chess but he's lost
three times
the fact though is that he is dominant
in rapid chess he's won 16 times to
wesley so is eight
he must be the big favorite going to
this matchup and also being online
chessy ivanka does that make
nakamura the huge favorite here
absolutely we all know in the
online arena nakamura is king but also
he had such a miraculous recovery
yesterday so i will
feel that he has things riding his way
and hikaru himself actually got into the
mood again tweeting
he's making a nice little pun on his
opponent's name so
it turns out there is more to this
tournament so we'll see how he gets on
oh we definitely will uh wesley uh so
and hikarnakamura now the next
semi-final matchup is with between world
champion magnus carlsen
and jan pognati the russian david this
is a huge matchup what do you expect
from it that's right i mentioned jana
pomney actually historically has been
magnus carlsen's kryptonite
i was actually there when they were both
very young they're the same age
when they were eight nine years old they
were playing against each other and the
pomniacci was always beating magnus
carson
in recent times though in rapid chess
magnus has started to reassert control
he's won 15 times in rapid games against
the pony actually he's got to be the
favorite the momentum's with him
an online chess jovanka who got the
upper hand
among these two there well it's
definitely magnus magnus is the gold
instead he is the triple world champion
and
like classical chess with rapid chess
and blizz chess and the same is true of
online chess he really
is the emperor no one seems to be
beating him
and he seems so cool and collected
definitely the odds are in his favor
all right well actually the very first
game the very first round in the
skilling open
these two players met magnus scrolls
nina pognachi and the world champion he
got off to a
horrible start oh no
surely not we've seen a mouse slip kaya
no
he's dropped his queen on the wrong
square and we see the results just
popped up i think the game is over
i think he did resign has resigned it
wasn't wasn't the best of start
i was choosing between many strong
continuations there and
all of a sudden i have to to resign
the first semi-final round is about to
start we see
two players now three players getting
ready in the room
ikaru nakamura he's not there yet david
no that's right every player has
different ways of warming up for the
game maybe he's just getting some fresh
air getting a drink
um he knows there's still a couple of
minutes left the others they're in the
zone they're getting focused wesley so
kind of looking very smart with his
glasses there magnus carson just trying
to
settle down starting to get concentrated
yeah and janna put me actually walking
around you
think he feels the nerves now before
facing the world champion yes definitely
that's a sign of being nervous of trying
to get
or walk off your excitement so
absolutely he's nervous
but at the same time excited as well and
the match that we will follow the first
game we will follow is between magnus
carlsen and
jan pomnyachien and they will meet each
other at least
three times today possibly four have
they made now preparations david for
all the four games or will they take it
as it goes that's right i think they'll
have a few different match
strategies in mind depending on how the
first few games go
they need to decide okay what do i do if
i want to play solid what do i do if i
need to win
there's so many different scenarios
they'll just take each game as it comes
but they definitely have a plan in mind
for the opponent
and we have to remind everyone that they
do have 15 minutes between each game so
they
play each other and as soon as they
finish 15 minutes starts
and they can well what can they do
ivanka relax eat drink
prepare what what do you think they do i
think that they relax i think
some players might meditate someplace
might jump up or down some players might
howl in frustration depending on the
result
it's uh anything goes basically and
magnus carlsen
everyone always calls him the favorite
just do you think he feels nerves now
before
a semi-final against someone he played
so many times i think
occasionally maybe but the reason he is
the world champion is because he can
deal with those nerves he can channel
that energy
into being productive on the board um we
see magnus carson
just disappeared there for a moment yeah
yeah maybe that was why he was so
concentrated he was fixing his webcam
and apparently has fallen up probably it
will come back yanaponyacci is
sitting there and we actually have
talked to all the players about if they
prefer
to see their opponent if they have the
web camera up or if they prefer
um not to um what do you think with
these two players
yeah i know magnus carlson he's admitted
he likes to pull the camera up
occasionally maybe not the whole time
he doesn't want to get distracted by the
opponent but it's nice to see the
expressions occasionally
and there he is all dressed up looking
nice for the semi-finals and it is
magnus with
white pieces who will make the first
move here and
uh do we have any expectations i i think
if he's feeling aggressive if he really
wants to win he'll push a pawn in front
of his king forward
two squares that's normally his
trademark move the trademark of nearly
every world champion
um i think possibly he's wanting to be
solid though and jana pomney actually
they know
each other so well it's all about who
gets to surprise their opponent early in
the game
yeah everyone is in suspense and we have
a fantastic
tweet from carl portman who says what a
thrilling prospect the russian bear
against the norwegian wolf both have
claws and fangs and
big reputations but they need confidence
cunning strength and an iron will to
survive
let the fur fly that's a perfect
description and we have started david
do we see cloth already yes we do we see
that magnus carson he's actually gone
onto his opponent's
home turf um janna pontiacchi ever since
he was young ever since these guys were
rivals at a young age
he's been playing an opening called the
grunfeld defense as black
janet probably actually he likes to
counter-attack that opening shows that
he
he's welc well he's welcoming white to
try and attack him but he's going to
stay strong
and then pounce at the right moment and
magnus carson this is a very brave
decision
going into something that his opponent
knows so well that shows that magnus
carson he's probably spent the whole of
this morning
studying the pontiac's games studying
what he's uh
what will probably happen on the board
and there we see a set of knights have
left the board
the first thing i noticed though is
white has two pawns in the center
two very nice pawns in the center napoli
actually has to decide how to counter
against those pawns uh yeah very solid
starts the game but i'm
liking what magnus carlsen's doing he's
provoking his opponent he's saying
i know what you're gonna do and i'm
ready for it exactly i love it because
you go into your opponent's
home ground and you're just there come
on look what i've got prepared for you
i know that i'm better than you even on
your territory love it
that's right and we saw that on the last
turn black brought his king
on the right-hand side of the board he
castled that king he moved it across two
squares he swapped around the rook
with it that's i mean that's what we
should always do in the opening stage to
keep our king nice and safe
magnus carlsen in reply just pushes his
queen forward
just one square just gaining a bit more
um scope with that queen
you want to develop all of your pieces
towards the center early on in the game
next he'll be thinking about what to do
with his king what to do with his knight
his bishop
lots of things to um think about and
that's why napoli actually spending a
little
bit of time here and in fact this is a
position that
both iana pomniacci and magnus carlsen
have faced with the black pieces
so uh very intriguing yeah that
that's right that means both players
will have studied this position before
napoli actually he's having a think he's
probably thinking
oh this must be preparation this must be
a bit of home cooking from magnus carson
what has he got in store for me um yeah
napoli actually he develops his knight
towards the center there very sensible
move
um he's attacking one of white's pawns
in the center of the board
and therefore white also brings a knight
towards the center he also develops it
just keeping his central horns nice and
safe and we see an advance in the center
of the board
magnus carlsen pushing forward lots of
action here
upon lots of pieces being traded bishops
have left the board
knights have left the board um white's
bishop that has just zoomed up towards
the black king to capture an opponent's
bishop an enemy bishop
um black's king could recapture there
and there's
lots and lots of action happening um
maybe if we bring up the announcers
board we see that there's
plenty of choice um black's king has
just recaptured this bishop here
two black pieces are under attack white
has a choice which one do you take
white has decided to take the bishop and
we see a knight in the center
lots and lots of action and magnus
carson has castled on the opposite side
to his opponent
yes and we know that that means david
that means a war is about to begin
gonna go crazy and start attacking we
love it okay so is this a message from
magnus carlsen that he is going for the
win
in this very first game yes he is going
for the win because one funny thing is
they are still repeating the games that
they themselves have played
oh so napomneti faced this against geary
in
july earlier this year and magnus
himself played against anand in 2014.
yeah that's right so magnus carlsen has
a lot of experience in this type of
position before
he here we see he's pushed his bishop
out to the edge of the board bishops are
very long
long range pieces so he's just keeping
an eye on a very nice
long diagonal there with that bishop
napoli actually he's got his head down
he knows he's seen this position before
he studied it he acts like this when
he's trying to recall
what he's looked at before maybe he's
got some coaches who've told him what to
do in this position but it's just a
memory game he's trying to recall things
now
magnus carlsen meanwhile he's i mean
he's nearly got
17 minutes on the clock he's gained
almost two minutes since we started the
game
he's so he's been in his preparations
this this whole time this
this was his plan the whole time this
was his plan
he went right he knew that napolita was
going to go into this line based on his
earlier games and he decided i'm going
to go
all for it and this is the secret move
moving that bishop to that square on the
kings on the left hand side of the ball
that's right and um i mean that's what
the opening stage
now that both kings have castle they're
both relatively safe those kings
um so the opening has ended but magnus
carlsen he's still been able to predict
all of his opponent's moves
that can be scary if you imagine
napomiacci now he knows he's been
predicted
all of those moves have been predicted
he knows that magnus carlsen is ready he
doesn't want to keep allowing magnus
carlsen to like blitz out those moves to
drop those moves on the board and
napoli actually pushes his king back he
retreats his king
one square very safe move but maybe a
bit of a slow one it shows that he's not
attacking
he's reacting and one more very quick
move from magnus yeah this is
all preparation for magnus he has been
there
on the on the board in this position in
the morning
so this is great stuff and magnus
carlsen so often is
uh praised for his intuition uh for his
endgame play
uh do we sometimes forget that he's also
excellent at opening preparations and
doing the homework
that's right actually magnus carson he
has a great team of coaches around him
they often feed him different ideas and
he's the one he
he picks and chooses what he likes the
look of he picks positions from them
that he thinks oh i can attack from here
oh this one i can
really put pressure on my opponent and
i'm sure one of his
coaches has suggested this line to him
and he said yes that is the idea to use
against the pontiac
and we see that white has just moved his
queen across one square eyeing up that
black knight in the center of the board
and we see him napoleon you described
david the way he's thinking the way he's
moving you can see he's really trying to
memorize
um what he knows about this this
position and how he can make it work for
him
yeah i think he magnus is calm as
anything
but nepomniacci now is on fresh
territory he has to work out what has to
be done
he has to work out how he is going to
start attacking
the white king on the left-hand side of
the board how he can open up lines
because we've discussed it for
it's the currency for attack you need to
open lines and he also has to decide
what to do
with that central knight okay and he has
moved the queen to the oh and look at
the bar it
says this is completely winning for
magnus
i'm shocked magnus he's frowning i think
this is a blunder
i think that might be a blunder i'm
trying to work out why
um why napoli actually has played that
move so
we see there he's just shuffled his
queen across he's defending his
knight right now but maybe this knight
is trapped
white can attack this knight one more
time he can push his pawn forward
um attacking this knight maybe there's a
trick maybe he can move this night
there's another option for magnus carson
he can break the connection between
black's queen and black's knight he can
push his central pawn forward
maybe this is the move that napoli
actually has missed cutting the
coordination between his queen and
knight
and suddenly i think white is going to
win a piece i think that knight is
doomed if
the pawn captures the pawn white can
trap this night now this knight has no
safe square
it's pretty much game over already wow
if magnus carlsen finds this idea
all right well let's see the faces of
the players like
right now instead you saw magnus
frowning
that he he was definitely surprised by
that move but then look at him he looks
pounced and ready to start
he knows this i mean moving that queen
to defend the night in such a way
it looked so bizarre to me david i just
couldn't fathom
and it's so passive and uh yeah of
course david pointed out a fantastic
line and then just
wins on the spots said and it doesn't
look like napogniachi has
realized that he might have blundered
horribly okay
he will now he will not
actually face i think he's slowly
starting to realize what he's done
oh yes he realizes oh
napoleon realizes he is there's a loss
for him in the first game already
already imagine magnus carson he's still
in his homework probably he's probably
even studied this exact position before
and the pony actually he's just been
caught unawares he's been caught by
surprise
it's pretty much game over we see that
we the bar underneath the player is this
green bar it's
all the way over to white side now that
means the white is completely winning
plus 3.6 that means more than three
pawns ahead
at this point that's because black's
knight is trapped in the center of the
board
and in prominently he simply had not
seen that pawn move
that possibility for magnus carlsen yeah
it was just i mean
if you look at the pawn move now it
looks a bit strange to
march your pawn one square forward where
the queen protects it
and the pawn is also attacking it so
that's why it was a very unexpected move
but it's such a brilliant move because
it interrupts the coordination between
the queen
and the knight and there really is
nothing for it
for in napomniachi what do we expect
from uh
janna pogniacci now i expect maybe some
few moves
just because really how moves out we're
16 we are 16
moves in and no one wants to lose on the
20 moves otherwise you go into that
horrible collection that's called
the book of miniatures and you don't
want to go in there so i expect some
some like just to come spike moves and
then i think we'll see
a game too in progress that's right as
you rank mentioned
it's it's just a badge of honor as a
chess player that we never lose
i mean especially these top players they
nearly never lose under 20 moves
it's just almost unheard of and to be
losing a piece
this early on in the game napominati i
think he's going to pause here just for
a couple of minutes
okay he has played pawn takes pawn we
will see magnus carson's next move
um immediately his pawn has advanced
white's pawn has advanced to attack that
knight in the center of the board
that night is trapped napoleon actually
he's just gonna find a way to try and
survive to just keep the game going as
long as possible
to hope that magnus carlsen either gets
nervous or makes another mouse slip i
think that's the only chance but
napoleon's face there he looks disgusted
he
yeah i think he knows it's already game
over
yeah you can see it there he is uh i
think he's emotionally
absorbed himself of this game and that's
it
wow what a
devastating start to the day foreign
i mean it is every chess player's
nightmare to lose on 20 moves
and certainly it would be a complete
horror
to lose in such a public way as this
yeah that's right and there we see black
has just shuffled his rook across one
square
he's allowing his knight to be taken by
a pawn and knight is
worth three points much more valuable
than that white pawn so
it's bad it's very bad transition here
for napoli actually but
he will get a couple of points he will
get a couple of pawns for that night
he'll try and keep the game going if he
can
it's not looking good but he knows okay
let's just keep this one going tire
magnus carson out slightly
before resigning before giving up and
moving on to the next one
wow and for magnus carlsen well a
shocking start i guess he didn't expect
jana pony at you to lose this already i
mean
in the opening yep it's a gift it's just
a gift you know you put hardly any
effort into the game and you've already
scored a point
so this is just a dream for
napomniatchi you can see in his face he
he knows
it's gone terribly downhill is it is it
actually a little bit
embarrassing for him this mistake he's
made yeah i think
ever so slightly he'll try and brush it
off that's what you have to do you have
to focus on the next game
but when he looks back on this match i
mean for example if he gets knocked out
tomorrow he'll look back on this game
and think this is where it all went
wrong
magnus carson actually not even
capturing that knight in the middle of
the board that knight is still trapped
it has
no safe squares just teasing him exactly
he's just rubbing it in he's saying i'm
not in a rush i'm just gonna
prove my pieces white brings the rook
towards the center he will capture that
night when it suits him
um magnus yeah i mean he's trying to
stay focused he's trying to keep his
poker face but i think inside he's
laughing
he's jumping up and down and to do this
in the grunfeld
which is napomniachi's territory this is
his bread and butter
yeah it's even even more painful oh and
it is painful looking at
his face he obviously realizes the
trouble he put himself in and we talked
so much about
oh let's take this move first that's
right so black has nothing to do that
knight has
no safe squares so he thinks okay i
might as well push my pawns forward
and we see black pushes upon on the left
there um it's the same side as white's
king
kind of it's a dream now that black can
try and push those pawns forward
open up squares open up lines towards
white's king but it's going to be far
far too slow and we see magnus casting
he's just playing with his food
now he's just teasing him he just
shuffles his king across one square he
knows there's no rush
um now he finally captures that knight
in the center
um black knight has disappeared he gets
a pawn for it
and white okay magnus carson he's not
even pausing to think he's pushed
another pawn forward attacking that
black rook now
in the middle of the board it's hard to
give any advice from the pontiac
absolutely it really is very difficult
just uh
he just needs to get over the uh the 20
move mark and he's done that so now it's
time to
pack up and uh try again yeah yeah
and we know magnus he you know oh
another move we'll take that first
right um if we just bring up the boards
now we can see that black is trying to
create threats
he just has to hope for a kind of a
moment of madness from magnus carson
black is attacking the white queen here
it's just a one move threat
but white has so many options for
example the queen could jump forward
and has been played that is like the
perfect attacking square
for a queen especially with black's pawn
formation on the right hand side of the
board
just to look at it it's right in the
middle there so napoleon really
trying hard he has pushed his left most
pawn
of the board and he's trying to indicate
some kind of aggressive intentions
but at the end of the day it's just a
pawn that is attacking
white's king and as long as magnus is
very careful then
nothing can go wrong that's right magnus
his pieces are all perfectly placed
right now
black as i mean as you vancouver
mentions black's only attacking with the
pawn a pawn cannot give checkmate on its
own
it's i think just two or three accurate
moves and we will see napoli actually
give up
it is minus uh thinking and um we know
he's been
bantering on twitter with anishgiri i
never get to ask this question
they keep playing these fast moves is it
something interesting happening
um white's just trying to keep the king
uh his king shelter he's just trying to
keep it blocked
um that left side of the board white's
king is just trying to maintain as much
safety as possible
as long as black's queen doesn't get
into the game as long as black's queen
is stuck
deep in his own camp um then white's
king isn't
extremely safe magnus carlton just
playing very sensible chess
yeah but as long as that white queen
exists on its beautiful square
right in the heart of the black camp i
don't think an important nazi can even
dream about
attacking this white king so yeah
bad news bad news there but you have to
remember david that
every single game does count because it
will lead to elimination it's the
semi-finals and whoever gets
whoever gets to get is the victor ends
up in the final
and we also have to think about those
poor people who have been eliminated
from the tournament
yeah that's right the players who are
eliminated especially in the first round
they can actually be voted back in can't
they ivanka
they can be voted in and in fact we have
seen some of those eight players on the
campaign trail
and we have a tweet from sergey karek
and says if you'd like to see me play
the next major you can premium members
can vote here and if you're not premium
member yet
there is a 50 percent offer right now
which means it's black friday you like
it friday you've got to take advantage
of those deals it is an
excellent time to become a premium
member on chess24 and we also have a
tweet from
vidit who also is asking there is a
chance for me to play in the next event
of champions chess tour by voting me
back in if you're a chess 24 premium
member
please do vote below additionally you
can become a chess24.com at a
as discount because it is black friday
yeah you can use the code bf2020
yes so everyone head into
championshipstore.com and get your
50 tour passes and then you can vote
back in
one of the eight players that left us in
the preliminaries they will
be voted one of them will be voted back
in for the major that starts december
26th
i've already voted oh have you can you
say who you voted for
yeah i was honest about it i really i
love the
underdog and for me the most unexpected
uh
player in that tournament was liam le
quang
and you know he played some fantastic
chess especially at the end when he came
back
and he is such a nice guy and i love the
nice guys
so he's a great smile so i voted for him
and he was so close to qualifying for
top eight as well
who would you vote for david oh that's
too close to paul i think there's so
many options we could vote for peter
svidler
who's one of the most popular
commentators on chess24 i mean he'd be
24 wouldn't have their commentator
i mean we saw that the tweet from vidit
the young indian he's got so many fans
i'm a huge fan as well
he played some great games in that
preliminary stage
he'd be one of my favorites karjakin
ali reza russia liran dingeren to be
honest they're
all great players so you can't go wrong
it's just the
christopher judah who keeps beating
magnus carlsen
yes well the choice is yours it's a hard
choice but
uh if you're going to championship.com
you will be able to buy the tour passes
50
off and you will be able to vote for the
player you want back in
champions chess tour fantastic i do hear
uh the players keep
playing some moves uh i'm guessing it's
still
a dead loss for yana pognacci that's
right it might be black friday but
this game is doomed
another pawn has left the board magnus
carlsen did win a pawn if we bring the
board up
um just to show the last couple of moves
very nice idea here by magnus carlton he
did
win a pawn in the center it is teamwork
the queen and rook ganging up together
this was actually a sacrifice and we see
another sacrifice um black just shuffled
his queen across the board
white has dropped his dropped his bishop
sorry
um in the center here look at this the
bishop is lining itself up
with the black king this is beautiful
chess um
this bishop is actually giving itself up
it's sacrificing itself
if the pawn captures the bishop it looks
like magnus carson he's just lost a
piece
but this was a sacrifice white is just
going to shuffle his rook across here
and the rooks together on this open line
these rooks love open lines they're
going to
penetrate the black position next move
an unstoppable move pretty much
white is just going to drop up his rook
to the back rank
to blacks black's first rank and he's
going to get at the black king
black's gonna have to give up his queen
now um it's not just that night that he
lost earlier black's queen is about to
disappear from the board
this is game over and the critical piece
in that whole attack is that
beautiful queen and i just love the way
that bishop came in it's like mic drop
[Laughter]
there you go master you can just imagine
the pawn
walking up there with the with the
microphone yeah yeah
i just love that move i mean it's it's
an artistic move as well
he's already ahead by a whole bishop he
doesn't need to take risks but magnus
carson he's so confident that he's happy
to sacrifice that bishop
just to get at the black king um that's
the artistic way of finishing it off
i'm yeah personally i'd just be playing
slow and steady chess but magnus carson
he loves to entertain the fans
yeah that's that's an impressive move
beautiful it
always seems like the most fantastic
chess moves and the mo
the moves are most remembered are the
ones that finish with
sacrifice the queen sacrifice or or
bobby fischer's pawn sacrifice or
the sacrifices yes everybody loves to
sacrifice
and that is a thrill that we get because
we give up a piece because
a lot of times we're quite attached to
the material but you give up a piece you
open some lines you hunt the king and if
the game ends in checkmates well that's
an even added bonus
wouldn't that be horrible for jana
pognati in this game she
also ended in a checkmate yeah that's
right that's
that's another thing that chess players
i mean we hate to lose but we hate
getting checkmated
and it has finished magnus carlsen has
won
the first semi-final game against jan
and pognatchi
fantastic start for the world champion
yeah that's
uh i mean yeah no problem actually he's
actually almost smiling there he knows
that that was
kind of an embarrassing game magnus
carlsen just wiped him off the board
we're only on move 26 and black has had
to resign
uh he just needs to bounce back now
magnus could just storm through and win
all the rest of these games if diana
pomnicci can't recover
yeah it's a critical every point counts
in this
setup because you know if he if he loses
the match
then he will have to fight back so hard
tomorrow and that might be impossible
and he's going to remember this this one
move that he did
um in his very first game in the
semifinals the
both players still sitting there looking
at the board
it should jump actually just forget this
now just don't look at that move start
preparing for the next game
yep and that is what he has to do in a
nutshell but
it's easier said than done because you
always think oh how embarrassing
in my own opening as well it's not ideal
but he has to do that that is the
correct mindset to be present
focus and just be thinking right i have
my second game i can do this
but he hasn't even left the table and he
hasn't left the computer and that
worries me
because he should go out and just reset
yeah
and we saw magnus carlsen also sitting
there did this come too easy for him in
the first game
he didn't even look happy yeah exactly
he knows there's still three tough games
ahead
potentially he knows that nanpomi
actually will never play this badly
again in his life probably ever so um
yeah i think magnus still trying to stay
in the zone he can't relax now just
because he's won a game
just because it was that easy he can't
relax so david
they were in the opening magnus seemed
to have planned all of this
and then the devastation comfort and
pogonia
could you show us again uh what happened
here that's right so if we
bring up the board now we see that
white's last move a very calm move
something that magnus carson he'd
clearly studied before he moved his
queen forward
just attacking this knight in the middle
of the board and the fight
all revolved around this night this
knight doesn't have too many safe
squares
napoli actually made a big big mistake
now he defended it with his queen
he used his queen to defend his knight
but he forgot that this knight has no
safe squares he was actually trying to
set a trick here
a very very cunning trick napoli
actually here he was hoping that magnus
would advance upon attacking this knight
but this would allow black to survive
black could actually move this knight
give it up and once it gets captured
black's queen suddenly zooms up the
board to take this pawn
with a double attack a check and next
move the bishop will drop the bishop
will be taken
but magnus carlsen stopped that idea he
cut the coordination
between the queen and the knight he
stopped that teamwork by
pushing upon advancing this pawn giving
it up in order to trap the black knight
and now we see
black's queen is terrible it's just
stuck behind its own pawns
black's knight is helpless it's all of
its squares are covered by this white
bishop
this bishop completely controls the
black knight the knight is trapped
black had to lose a piece and he
couldn't fight back
all right well that was the first game
in the semifinals between minus carlson
and jan no pognyacci and
easy and uh great friend for magnus
carl's niana pognachi
now needs to fight back and as we wait
for their next game to start
we do have a guest joining us and it is
leonard claussen he is the co-founder
um of the presenting partner for the
skilling open
skilling open uh leonard hi hi
how are you hey we're good what a start
yeah what a start
exactly how are you uh watching all this
drama unfold
oh yeah no i think it's nice i love
watching chats online
uh on tv uh i think i think it's great
um
obviously watching magnus as a norwegian
it's been some fantastic years so glad
to hear that
yeah so glad you heard that and
obviously we keep hearing
skilling open the skilling skilling open
uh can you actually tell us
uh what is the core business of skilling
yeah i mean most of all we're a tech
company
that connects people to the most uh
popular financial markets around the
world
so we're providing a trading platform
where you can trade more than 800
instruments everything from
forex to shares to cryptos and and
whatever you want i would say
um we also provide free training
through demo accounts and we have our
own skilling academy
and yeah we provide daily analysis in
order to help people
improve their skills in in within
trading so
uh yeah we we believe we are an
intuitive
user-friendly and secure and transparent
alternative
in in something that we know is
perceived as a
somewhat complex area to be honest
but of course when it comes to trading
there will always be some
criticism and um what is um i mean who
who are the right customers
for the services that skilling offers
yeah
well i would say i'm trading
just like chess it's very hard to master
it
so it means that i mean no one can
simply just start off with trading and
expect to be uh immediately successful
at it
so uh just just as a newbie chess player
he wouldn't expect to sit down for his
first match and beat the grandmaster you
you have to expect
a a quite long learning curve but but
it's not impossible to learn that that's
very important to say
so and as i mentioned i mean we we
provide this free demo account so that
people can
can start off and trade on uh yeah with
virtual money so they don't have to
to to risk any actual money here and uh
yeah we we think our products are there
for for those who really want to learn
uh and yeah learn about trading and and
to grow
within trading and actually
talking about trading we hear the term
trading all the time in chess trading
the bishops trading the queens
um are there any similarities between
your kind of trading and chess
oh yeah well i mean that i can go on
forever with that i think
there's so many similarities i already
mentioned a few but uh
i mean maybe it's a good thing to to
compare uh
or to look at this like if you do
trading
like if you play a game of chess to i
mean to be
successful and i mean in trading the the
opponent would obviously be
the market you will have to have a plan
and a strategy before you start
uh just uh as you're doing inches and
you cannot just
buy or sell randomly products you you
need to or
you cannot randomly move pieces around
the board and to edit
and to be able to create this plan you
need the knowledge
about the specific market or maybe your
specific opponent
what does he normally do or how does
this market normally
uh react um and also before you start
you
you have to do a lot of analysis and i'm
100 sure and every just very familiar
with that
um and i mean during a match and
during a session of trading uh you you
sure have a lot of help if you have the
experience because you have to
you have to act and you have to react to
what your opponent does or
what happens in the market i mean even
now you have on the board you have to
you have to consider the risk before you
make your next move
you cannot just do it randomly and and
they precision i mean
if you execute a move or a trade you you
have to be precise
i mean one wrong move here as we saw
just few minutes ago it can destroy the
whole match
or you can lose money in trading and
then
yeah i mean the last two things i have
to mention i mean
patience is a key word you need to be
patient
both when you gain the knowledge maybe
that's the boring part
but also when you're in the middle of it
and i've seen it so many times
when a player or a trader becomes
impatient he will make a mistake you
have to make for that
yeah right spot where you can make your
best move whether it's on the board or
in the market
and and and finally i would say emotions
which is
i guess next or if we can see nakamura
later on i mean that's so funny
he i mean as a trader you you have to
control
your emotions and it's the same with
chess player
it's not always easy to hide or suppress
but but
i mean yeah looking at nakamura when
when he
realized he'd done something wrong it's
just it's just funny to watch but
even though if he loses that match i'm
pretty sure he he
he comes back stronger after after
calming down
and and also sure he will spend a lot of
time analyze this
or analyzing his uh his mistake and
learn from that
and let's not forget about the mutual
fantastic feeling
of victory when you actually succeed
because
of course fantastic okay leonard thank
you so much for
well uh comparing the two uh chess and
trading obviously um much similarities
there and
we are so glad that skilling uh has
decided to to team up with the champions
chess tour
um and partner with the tour and with
magnus carlsen thank you so much for
joining us
yeah thank you thanks for being here all
right well david obviously many
similarities here
is it true that if you're good at chess
you're also good at trading
well possibly i don't have any
experience myself but i'm actually
fascinated by trading a few of my
best friends they are in that game and
they love it
and i i mean it was just so interesting
to hear about those similarities you
know i heard a rumor
many years ago that grand masters were
being recruited by the city of london
just to trade because they're very good
with numbers and i do know of certain
grand masters who
are actually millionaires as a result of
trading all right
well we're so glad that skilling has
decided to team up with the champions
chester
uh for and um for this event the
skilling open
now um let's go to something very
controversial
we asked the chess players wait maybe
one of the most controversial questions
you can ask
take a look
[Music]
that's a hard pass for me i just find
pineapple you know i find it highly
objectionable i actually like this
combination
never had one and doesn't sound very
lucrative
in general i'm against sweet things on
food that is not dessert
italians feel very bad about their
food being destroyed so i would say
pineapple on pizza is probably a no
because i
support their course the last time i had
pineapple on my pizza was probably
uh 11 years ago back when i was living
in the philippines i don't think i've
tried it before
it's not a good mix but i still
sometimes i order it
because i like pineapple so
[Music]
all right well david anton he likes
pineapple he likes pizza how do you feel
you like a pineapple on pizza
i love it oh very controversial
david how about you yeah just the more
the merrier i'd throw it throw
everything on my pizza
and i'll eat it wow okay so you're not
against the sweet stuff on the
the traditional italian pizza nope all
right
well do you think uh jana pogniacci and
mine scrolls now had time to have some
pizza or pineapple or both
in between their games now it's about to
start the next one i think if anyone
needs it it's napoli actually
he needs something to spice him into
life he needs something to just
help him forget about the last game and
refocus
what is this next game all about for him
no iwanka he does have white pieces
yeah it's just about recovery he just
has to get motion because the other
the first game he it will feel like he
didn't really get a chance he made one
howl of a move and that was it game over
so now it's just about
perhaps taking a draw perhaps playing it
slow and steady and just getting
into the mood to play good chess
and we see them already sitting there i
will also mention that hikaru nakamura
and wesley so they're still
playing their first game i'm just
looking at the bar and it looks
sort of dryish but we will of course
keep you posted on what happens there
as jana pognyacci is getting ready to
make his first move
and i keep asking you david but do you
think we will see blood from the
beginning here
i think we will i think napoli actually
he's not the type of player to play for
a draw
we did see in the preliminary stage
sometimes he tried to force a draw with
white
but it's just not his style he's very
aggressive he's very uncompromising and
if he does go all out for the win either
that'll be fantastic and we'll see
fireworks or we might see magnus carlsen
counter-attack and punish him it might
rebound
so i think either way we'll be in for a
battle and we did see him
do what he had to do he threw away his
cell phone he's not
allowed to have that by his side when
he's playing very strict regulations of
course so the players do not cheat
of course they wouldn't cheat they're
professionals and magnus carlsen
just have that same game game phase all
day
yeah he is the boss let's face it oh and
then ponyoshi switched his cop
he's always had this white coffee mug
and i
just saw it there it was yellow now ah
perhaps he has
lucky mugs lucky mug alright he is going
to need it he is down by one point
after the very first game in the
semi-final they do play
one match today containing on four games
and one match tomorrow
uh with four new games and if magnus
carlsen or
iana boniacci reaches two and a half
point by the three gave
three first games today they do stop
playing then the first player to two and
a half points is the winner of day
one and jana pogba actually needs to
strike back now he definitely
he cannot have a loss here and that
would be devastating
no absolutely it would be absolutely
traumatizing if he were to
lose again and if he were to lose in a
way like for instance like david
mentioned
that he went too hard for the attack and
magnus
carlsen just counter-attacked and he
would lose that would just be awful
okay so he has put his king's horn
two squares forward so this is already a
signal
that things are going to perhaps get a
little bit aggressive
that's right we see magnus cast in his
clocks ticking maybe he doesn't realize
the game has started
magnus depending on his mood will react
either by copying
black by pushing a pawn in front of uh
white's pawn there
in front of his own king that's kind of
the move he plays when he wants to be
solid or he might go for something
called the sicilian defense which is a
bit more aggressive
it really depends on his style here
depends on his mood i really like the
webcams there
napoli actually his kind of his lighting
he's white in this game he knows he
needs to win magnus carlsen is sitting
in the dark
um he knows that he needs to hold this
game with black at the very least hold
it
to keep the momentum on his side but
magnus the game started
there he is there he is he pushes a pawn
forward
this is one it might okay it's not
heading towards your favorite opening
kayak
it's not heading towards the sicilian
night off but it is a sicilian
defense by black this is what magnus
carson plays when he's hoping that he
gets a chance to counter-attack
it's it's not his most solid opening he
first started using it regularly in a
world championship match
against fabiano caruana in 2018
so he does trust this opening as black
but it does mean we'll have a really
tense and balanced game a bit later on
and the probably actually having to
think what to do here
already and i mean magnus hardly spent
any time on his clock in that first game
he didn't really have to
um will this perhaps get more
complicated
i think napoli actually will want to
keep more tension on the board
but maybe this is also a difference
between the player's homework magnus
clearly spent this morning studying that
opening that we saw in the last game
and that really helped him i mean he
pretty much guided him to victory in
that last game
napoli actually it looks like he's well
he's taken a couple of pauses
he's playing slightly quicker now maybe
he's just trying trying to freestyle
just trying to get magnus into a
position he hasn't studied before
different strategy there we see that
black after a couple of trades of pawns
in the center of the board white's
knight in the center there black has now
castled which means moving your king
across two squares
switching it with a rook this is
something to do to keep your king safe
in every game
very safe sensible play by magnus
they're probably actually
retreating a bishop there just dropping
a bishop back
the moves are coming thick and fast yeah
this this actually has never been played
by magnus carlsen himself before so
definitely new territory for him that's
right it's actually one of magnus's
uh one of his coaching team daniel dubov
a russian a very young russian player
he magnus said daniel dubov inspired him
a couple of years ago when they first
started studying chess together
and this is one of dubov's favorite
openings so he's kind of using an idea
that one of his friends plays and that's
i think that's how
for people at home as well who are first
starting to learn the game that's a
really useful tip
just play with your friends maybe pick
up a few ideas that you like of theirs
try and learn from them you can kind of
both improv well both improve both push
each other to improve them
that's what even world champions do that
they use other people too
exactly and it's a lot more fun to be
honest to play chess with your friends
a bit of banter insult each other
[Laughter]
and donald dubo you mentioned him a
player we hopefully get to see later on
in the champions chess tour
um and is it important actually for for
magnus as the world champion to
to stay humble and keep learning and
take ideas also from other chess players
yeah i i wouldn't use the word humble to
describe magnus
i mean he has more of a kind of working
relationships where
he gets sent information by his seconds
and he looks at it and says i like that
or i don't like it
it changes so
it's not necessarily humble all right i
can't imagine
i think the main thing is he doesn't get
complacent he's always trying to push
himself to new levels that's the
that's what sets him apart his game
always evolving he's always trying to
improve
and actually if we bring up the board
here we see that magnus he's
okay he's just played a porn move but he
is trying to take his opponent's bishop
black's knight there on the left-hand
side
he is trying to capture a bishop with
that knight normally this is another
thing we tell people not to do
especially when they're first starting
out the game
don't put your knights on the edge of
the board but there has to be a reason
if you do
and black's knight will soon capture a
bishop
meanwhile white has also copied black's
recent idea he's also castled his king
to the right side there
both kings very very safe this will
become more of a maneuvering battle now
it will become a fight for the center
and fight for territory yeah
now i really liked his his night
excursion we've been very critical about
putting your knight on the edge of the
board as david says but the night
excursion
to that edge that's on the right on the
left hand side is
primarily because he wants to trade that
bishop because if you look at that
bishop
it points all the way all the way close
to the black king
and you just cannot have such a
dangerous piece
looking at your king like that that's
right so as you've even mentioned
this white bishop is the key piece in
this opening bobby fischer
a former world champion american world
champion in 1972 he loved this bishop
this light squared bishop
it was his favorite piece he said it won
him so many games and therefore magnus
carlsen
doesn't like that bishop looking at his
king he pushes his knight to the edge of
the board
kind of breaking the kind of traditional
advice there but it is going to take
that bishop
very very soon um i think that will be a
very favorable
trade for magnus carlson if he can get
it bobby fischer the former american
world champion and
the battle between the two americans in
the skilling open nakamura and wesley so
the first game has ended in a draw
so they will play their next game the
second game
in 10 minutes or so i think so slow
start for them whilst magnus carlsen got
the first win against janna pomnyacci in
their first game and
they are fighting now in the second game
and i tried to ask this question
so many times in the first game it was
so fast i will ask this question now so
magnus carlsen seems to rival with a lot
of players what is the relationship
with him and jana pognacci i think
they're good friends
i i their chubby they've been childhood
rivals but my understanding is that
they're very good friends
um off the board and i do know that
there came a time when nicolson was
looking for someone to be a second
and he needed someone who didn't respect
him too much
and he chose nipomnation wow very nice
friendly rivalry there
all right what do you say david you know
them both that's right i've known them
both for
longer than i could remember since we
were about eight nine years old i
i'm exactly the same age as these guys
you are too kyah yeah but i mean
we're all born in 1990 and that
generation of players they had so many
battles
um janna pomney actually actually in
these young age groups so for example in
the world under 10 championship he was
the dominant force
um the world under 12 championship there
was one year that magnus carlsen
well i played him in the final round and
both of us if we won we would get the
gold medal we would have won the world
championship but we ended up drawing
against each other and
napoli actually he won his last game
he got that gold medal and i remember
magnus didn't talk to me for seven years
after that
um i don't think he talked to napolita
for seven years after that but now
luckily we all need to know each other
we're all good friends i think there's a
lot of mutual respect between these two
guys
and we have a tweet that agrees with you
david from carl portman who says world
champions never ever coast
fisher kasparov carlson all pushed
themselves to their limits to stay ahead
of the opposition
so yeah and if you want to join and the
conversation the fun
the banter in the studio then please do
tweet us
using the hashtag chess champs that is
the hashtag you need to use and it is so
fun to get all the comments
yeah absolutely all right david we do
hear
some more moves coming in i see the bar
is still uh
saying that this is dryish yeah that's
right i think it's
the position is roughly level still
chances for both sides
um if we bring up the board just to show
the last couple of moves not too much
has happened we saw that
uh white just advanced his queen
slightly one square
it's really nice having the queen and
bishop on the same line teaming up
together
maybe something could happen on this
diagonal later white might advance his
bishop
towards black's king in the meantime
like pushes his bishop
along one square this is the dream
diagonal for every bishop you want to be
on as
long a diagonal as possible long term
those bishops might become very powerful
if pawns start to leave the board
therefore magnus says okay your bishop's
developed itself i'm going to block your
bishop
and with his last move he just pushes
his pawn just forming a really nice pawn
wall a pawn chain
the all these pawns are going to try and
block out this black bishop over here on
the left so
very sensible stuff from both sides
early days and magnus carlsen's last
move bringing a rook into the game rooks
love open lines
both players doing exactly what they
should do okay who would you rather be
here white or black
if you came into this position right now
i think i would prefer to be black
because black's position just looks easy
to play they have control
of and half open line just look at that
rook on that line
and they control some few squares white
really needs to play
a bit hard they need to go a bit forward
with their pieces
and for that reason i'm going to prefer
black because it's just an easier
position to play
i'll say white just to be difficult
um i do think the position is roughly
level both sides have
different plans there's so much tension
there's only been one pawn each
leaving the board so far so this one is
early days but it's warming up nicely i
think this one's going to slowly slowly
build up
and then explode a bit later on early
days
ivanka likes black i like white let's
see who's going to be proven correct
and the white bishop has moved all the
way to the right hand side of the board
and is right in the enemy camp
and the reason they played this is to
exchange
off that very important dark squared
bishop that is surrounding the black
king this is an important protector
didn't you say david that bobby fischer
liked the
light squared bishop why why would he
like the light square bishop and not the
darth vader bishop
that's right i mean i think he loved it
when they were both together as a team
but in general um it's just because of
how he opened the game
that white squad bishop was always the
most powerful in every opening he chose
somehow
in his lines i mean he loved to push his
pawn forward in front of his king
two squares on the first go he always
said pawn to e4 that was the best by
test
and it just happened that that bishop
coordinates really well with the pawn
here
um okay some exciting stuff there david
is getting excited yes i am because
magnus has in fact
traded off those bishops and now it's a
queen that we see
suspiciously close to the black king i
always get slightly
concerned when there's a queen hovering
around
a king that's right white's queen now so
close to the black king you can imagine
if that queen gets some support if it
might
be able to team up with a night later
there might be a checkmate
um to the black king so that's why we
see magnus carlsen push a pawn in the
center he's trying to kick this knight
away
he's trying to kick this knight away
from potentially
linking up with his own queen um the
white queen it needs support though it
can't check mate all on his own black is
just about defending
it's very brave though allowing a queen
so near your king
normally i don't recommend this for
people watching at home but magnus
carson he'll think that
he has enough defenders he has this
position under control
um and then we see white's knight has
retreated so unable to link up with that
queen to attack
right now yeah he's breaking a little
bit of the raw book
here uh magnus is because he pushed his
central pawn forward but i get a little
bit worried because there
is a nice square in the center
in the middle of the board for white to
put their pieces and
it cannot be yes exactly and it cannot
be attacked
by pawns so we call those squares
outposts
and this this is very risky strategy
because if it all goes wrong
for black it means that white will
simply put a piece there
and black cannot do anything about that
piece that's right this square
jovanka mentions this square cannot be
controlled by black pawns
it's controlled by black pieces at the
moment but if those pieces disappear
then this is going to be the key square
in this game at the moment i think
napoli actually he's just wondering
which
piece should i improve there's no
immediate way to get at the black king
so therefore when in doubt just improve
a piece this rook
is doing nothing this rook could slide
itself towards the center
eyeing up the black queen um this is
what i would personally do here
as white but he might be thinking okay
black is also going to try his own
tricks
he's going to try and develop his queen
there might be a check along a long
diagonal
there's so many plans for both sides
it's just going to be a battle of wits
here who can trick the other one
so did you have you changed your mind
after seeing that move uh ivanka and
or those moves uh or would you still be
black would i still be black
um yes i would still be black yeah i
would definitely be
like um the only thing that i'm a little
bit concerned about is that
the risk involved in magnus's play
because like i said
if it all goes wrong you cannot make
that take those porn moves backwards
but on the other hand i do really like
that
rook that's on the open line i love the
knight on the edge of the board because
that's
also that's threatening to take the
bishop or perhaps is threatening to
jump in to white house white side of the
board by just hopping one square
um yeah it's so complicated here that's
right it's so much tension
there's also a small trick black's porn
that just advanced white cannot capture
it with the knight i don't think we'll
see that happen
but white is well white does have to be
slightly careful here i would personally
move that rook into the center of the
board or i would keep my king nice and
safe i would
tuck my king away in the corner there
for white um janna prominently though
either way he has to make a decision
he's four minutes below on the clock
we saw in the first game magnus played
so far so confidently
napoli actually normally it's the shoe
is on the other foot normally he's the
one bossing things putting the
opponent under pressure it feels like
he's out of his comfort zone maybe he's
been affected by that last game
and i actually did see him also drinking
from that white cup now so he's drinking
both from a yellow mug
and a white mug this is being greedy
yeah
exactly well he has to be careful
because he's not allowed to go to the
toilet during this game
and could it be a long game i mean as
long as a rapid game can be
yeah definitely we see i mean white has
eight minutes here black has 13 minutes
so the game could last over 20 minutes
now
also the the players do gain 10 seconds
after every move so
technically the game could go on forever
you definitely don't want to be
distracted by
a bursting bladder um later in the game
when
when the things are really starting to
yeah we actually have a question from
abdul majeed from on twitter he says
can you give more insight about how
grand masters prepare an opening for the
tournament
yeah it's very very fascinating question
that's right oh yeah great question
abdul and
i think there's a few different ways so
each player throughout their careers
they'll have their favorite openings
those will be openings for example we
saw in the pontiac in the last game with
black it's an opening he's played since
he was eight years old
and over the years he spent 20 25 years
honing that opening making sure that
when there are no holes he knows exactly
what to do no matter how his opponent
tries to attack him
but occasionally as we saw in that last
game occasionally you will find that you
run into trouble you don't want to be
too predictable
these guys at the top level they have
backup plans they have a second opening
a third opening
they know that if they run into trouble
in their favorite lines in their
favorite variations then they have
something to fall back on and i think
we'll see that later on
um it's nice to have an own opening for
example an attacking opening where you
need to win it's nice to have a solid
opening if you just want to
play for a draw you have to be prepared
for every scenario and uh
openings remember they're just about
getting you into the middle game it's
not about trying to win early on it's
just
trying to survive and getting a position
that suits your life uh suits your style
yeah i completely agree with you david
but these grand masters actually are
very special creatures because they you
had
let's not forget they have an army of
seconds and they have people feeding
them information
for the for the mere mortal i would say
it's just like for david and for myself
the advice that i've been given and i
think is fantastic advice is you have
two repertoires so you have one that you
play online
that you can just it's almost like it's
brainless you just make a few moves
and you just develop your pieces very
naturally and then you have one that you
play for over the board one
where you can dedicate a little bit more
time to and you kind of a little bit
more critical
because in online chess it's just about
being quick
and if you're just making moves at tempo
where you don't have to be 2600 to find
the best moves
that is the best way um so um and i i
know
these the grandmasters and and probably
you guys uh
have uh opening preparation
computers just packed with prep
is what i hear everyone calling it yeah
i mean how much prep can a chess player
have in a computer
a lot we have databases with millions
and millions of games
so yeah we do have a but we don't
memorize this
that's good to hear this is all
information that we have to hand so that
if we're preparing for someone you can
just pull up that database and you go
that is what i'm going to play and then
you reinforce your short-term memory
and if you have some repertoires and
you've bought yourself a book i know
that
there's some brilliant courses on
chesapore which is to do with
which uses the science of space
repetition so
every so often you get a test a memory
test and then if you get it wrong you
have to repeat it and then repeat it
again so these are kind of
tricks and techniques that we have in
order to kind of keep the memory fresh
it's a bit like an exam i have a 12 year
old student she always says okay i need
to revise my notes
just before your big game just before
your exam you just go over on the
computer you just play through things
repeat it
and that's best way the best way to
learn all right well they're playing a
lot of moves now what's happening
that's right so if we bring up the board
just to show what's happened over the
last few turns
we left it after black had advanced the
pawn on this left-hand side
he is trying to advance even further to
attack this white knight therefore
napoleon he said okay i'm going to stop
you advancing that pawn he just pushed
his pawn
covering this important square there
therefore magnus castle said okay
this bishop i might as well take it off
the board it's no longer looking at my
king now
across this diagonal that bishop was
traded for a night that's roughly a fair
trade knight's worth three points
bishop's worth three points
but then we see blacks opening the
center magnus carson
trying to open things up um for this
bishop this bishop was useless
pointing against white's very strong
pawns in the center he opened things up
a couple of pawns left the board
and now we see janna ponnyacci take a
timeout he just shuffles his king
to the corner very safe move this king
looking
i mean actually i'm not 100 sure i like
it this bishop
is looking at that king down the long
diagonal but
for now the king is very safe in that
corner another good piece of advice for
everyone just keep your king tucked away
behind pawns and that's what pontiac
is doing and also uh keep an eye on her
clock yana pognati is now
down to six minutes it's half the time
that magnus carlsen's got so it might
get tense for him here very soon yeah no
it's
definitely going to get tense and one
thing that really
really worries me and it's not an
immediate factor
but it's the fact that black if you
count the pawns
on the right hand side of the board
black has four pawns
and white has three which that means
that if the game fast forwards and goes
into an end game where pieces get traded
then this extra pawn can become
a past pawn now if you look on the
left-hand side of the board where you
see white has three pawns and black has
two
you can see that it's actually much more
difficult for whites to have that
brilliant past pawn and that is
something
that is going to be perhaps not
important now
but as soon as the game develops into
the later stages it's going to start to
play
more and more that's right i completely
agree with you ivanka
we've talked about doubled pawns on
previous days doubled pawns are normally
they're only bad when they're weak
and when they can be attacked but on
this occasion white does have doubled
pawns we see that on the left side
um just on over on the b file we call it
if you see the coordinates of the bottom
board the b those pawns
are doubled they are potentially weak
they also
it's as if it's just one pawn they don't
i mean having two
isn't that much better than having one
so white long term is essentially
down a pawn um we see magnus carson
meanwhile just developing his queen
bringing his queen to a slightly more
active square
napoli actually looks surprising yeah he
does
he does and we have a tweet from aide
kopi he says
the sicilian is white's worst nightmare
seems magnus is going
all out for a win today no i
i have to agree that was one of the
reasons i did not like to play this move
that's why it's
open with my king pawn yeah the sicilian
defense as well it's been the bane of my
life
uh all of my strongest rivals they all
played against me
it's so hard to find an advantage
against that opening this is an
uh silly defense and we see oh and the
bar shifts
quite a little bit for magnus there with
that move that's right so
um napoli actually he puts his knight in
the center of the board i
think that that's generally it's quite a
logical move knights are fantastic in
the center of the board your bank has a
name for those nights
octonauts in the last game
my octonaut got into trouble all right
well octo and i need to
also pay attention then exactly oh
that's a very very aggressive move
because that
night is headed into the center but it's
headed to another destination
that's right if we bring up the board we
can see napoli actually his plan over
the next two or three moves
he's just dropped his knight in the
center here he wants to jump
even further to help his queen we talk
about teamwork all the time in chess
you need to use all of your pieces
together and why tonight for example if
black
is a bit lazy a bit slow if he just
plays a move on the
left side not doing anything we can see
that white is going to jump in with his
knight
now we have a checkmate threat white's
queen and knight they're the dream
attacking combo these two pieces ganging
up against the same wheat pawn which is
only defended by a black king
again if black is clumsy if he just
forgets about that
then that we will see checkmate this uh
the queen and knight together they can
wreak havoc if there aren't any
defending pieces on the other side and
black needs to watch out for this one
magnus carlsen he needs to be a bit
careful of that night joining the action
yeah he he needs to be worried about
that but uh yeah
we also have some beautiful compliments
kaia and david so we
have a compliment from neely jay who
says loving the commentary
even i can understand the games being a
non-player just a chess
mom so thank you neely for watching and
we also got a compliment from nicholas
alpoin he says
chess champs loving the com coverage
with a british accent
best regards from uruguay south america
oh fantastic
it's so nice to hear especially when
they like the commentary
you know towards people my playing
strength
and and everyone that doesn't
necessarily have a chest rating
it's nice to actually understand what's
going on on the chessboard that's right
and people from all around the world
i've received messages from people in
montreal in canada from people in brazil
it's so nice to hear that everyone is
enjoying the show enjoying these games
between some of the best players yes
and uh magnus has taken the warning that
david gave him
and has pushed his pawn one square up
the board
in order to stop that knight getting to
that very very dangerous square
that's right so it's now harder for
white to use his queen and use his
knight to team up
black's last move this pawn move just
one square
advancing he is covering this night jump
that is a very classy move by magnus
carson he's seen his opponents plan
that's what we have to do in chess
that's what the first thing i think when
my opponent has made a move is what does
my opponent want next
and magnus carlsen he's stopped na
pomniacci's plan napoleon actually needs
a new plan
i just hope that he forgets well that he
doesn't forget to use his rooks in this
game
his queen is perfectly placed his
knights are well placed his rooks are
not active at all so
napoli actually with four minutes now
less than half of magnus carson's time
he needs to get his rooks
active he needs to get them into the
game
yeah absolutely he does need to do i
really
love that last move by magnus carlsen
such a beautiful
little move at the same time defends
absolutely everything and
again magnus has the long-term advantage
you have to remember
and uh i expect we're going to see one
of those
rooks get into the game and you've
called it david the rook has
moved from the right-hand side of the
board and it is now
challenging the black rook that's right
so the rooks are looking each other
on that line now um we could see a trade
of all of the rooks
i think ivanka mentioned earlier black
has a long-term advantage black's pawns
are just slightly better than whites
that means that trades exchanges do
favor black in general
but as long as the queens remain on the
board as long as lots of
uh as long as there's enough tension
white will always have
well a way to play for tricks we've
mentioned in previous days
knights are the trickiest pieces and uh
janna pomney actually he needs to just
create some
threats with those knights he needs to
set traps for magnus carson to fall into
it's all been a bit too comfortable for
magnus so far
especially after winning that last game
magnus okay magnus retreating his knight
there he's going to try and attack
white's queen soon black's king is the
only issue in his position
white queen very near the black king so
if he can evict that queen if he can
kick the white queen away
then black will be very very happy
another nice move for magnus a lovely
move
normally we're quite critical of
retreats but here this retreat
has been designed with a purpose and i
just love where that night is going to
be headed because it moved from the
center and it's going to
attack that queen it's also going to
look at squares
towards the white king i also just love
this black queen that is on the right
hand side of the board
because it can at the right moment come
in
all the way in i can't right now because
there's a knight covering that square
but if it was allowed to i
could get in to a square very very very
close
to the white king and that is dangerous
and yana pognachi going under
three minutes on his clock in something
very complicated here so this
is about to get very interesting yeah
roles have been reversed
jana pontiac we've seen nearly every
game he's played this tournament
in the preliminary stage in the knockout
stage he's always ahead on the clock
today that's not the case magnus carson
putting him under pressure on the board
and on time i'm very worried for
napoliyachi as we mentioned if he loses
this one it might be
all over today i don't think he's going
to battle back from two games down
no i don't think anybody's ever battled
back from two games down against magnus
carlsen
um there we see a pair of rooks being
traded white has captured
an enemy rook that rook is immediately
snapped off the board as well
actually napoleon is trying to trade off
all the rooks and we see the bar
slightly edging towards carlson's
direction
that's because black has the long-term
advantages black
is the one who is uh well he should be
slightly happier with the trades
i'm slightly surprised by napogniachi's
decision
but maybe he's hoping that the more
trades happen the more pieces come off
the board maybe he can hold a draw
it's not what he wants but it's better
than losing right now it's better than
being knocked out
yeah a loss would just be dreadful and
you can see that
magnus has taken off that night with the
bishop
and uh i'm expecting some big
trades coming in but i'm very worried
i'm very worried because black's queen
is
just so beautiful that's right white the
more pieces come off as well the more
kind of useless white's queen looks
white's queen tried to get at the black
king
but just doesn't have any backup um it
doesn't have any support
trying to attack there so um nice trade
by magnus carson a bishop for a knight
in the center
white's pawn we see with the green arrow
white's pawn has just captured a bishop
that pawn is isolated it has no pawns
around to defend it
later on that pawn might become weak in
the center of the board um
yeah still in the balance but magnus
carson he's the only one who can really
try and push this one for victory
i think napoli actually we see by his
face looking a bit sad he knows that he
just has to
buckle in and try and but does it does
it look like magnus is pushing for that
win actually
it does look like magnus could start
grinding it down
like we know he loves to do just slowly
squeezing
exactly make the right trades you know
you can just imagine if
all the pieces were traded off then that
extra pawn that black has on the right
hand side of the board is gonna start to
count
um yeah so this is what gives magnus
the advantage and also the clock also
the clock
the clock is a ticking time bomb isn't
it it goes down and the more it goes
down the more likely we're going to see
in a pony actually panic so and i just
and i've said it before many many times
but i'm a big fan of that
black queen because for me it's on a
goldilocks square
by goldilocks i mean it's perfect it's
neither too hot
too cold so she can jump forward if she
wants to get aggressive and come very
close
to the white king but also she can
centralize herself
super easily along that line so i mean
absolutely big fan of that and that's
right if we bring up the board just to
illustrate your
anchor's point um black's queen is
actually a lot better than the white
queen right now this black queen it can
jump into its position in just one move
it can also just defend everything
across this line
meanwhile white's queen is trying to get
at the black king but everything's
defended it's going to have to retreat
sooner rather than later
and personally i'm just looking at this
white pawn in the center of the board
it's got nothing around it
later on it will be a weakness it will
be a target
white has these doubled pawns which are
a bit useless on the left side there
i'm very worried about the features the
long-term features of the position
napoleon actually he needs to be very
accurate meanwhile magnus is
he's thinking here how do i set some
problems how do i try and get napoli
actually to panic
yes no i mean there's so many great
things about magnus's position it's just
just you know i'm also looking at the
potential of this knight
because there's one beautiful thing
about this position is that those
two pawns in the center they start to
control squares and if you look at
black's pawn
well it controls two squares and
if you imagine a knight getting into
those squares
then they would not only be in a white
bottom half of the board
but also one square on the right hand
side
would be looking at the king so there's
so many things like a great
potentially a great night potentially a
great queen
and uh yeah and also that yeah
it's uh it's a little more the more i'm
i'm looking at the more i'm liking it
and i'm thinking oh oh
oh you know you really think this is
beautiful don't you
oh that piece is so beautiful i always
imagine these engines a little bit like
red riding hood like with a basket i
will have a better night i will have a
better queen
and you know those little advantages
they actually collectively
some i mean they collectively build up
to something actually winning
that's right and we have seen the last
pair of rooks leave the board so now
each side just has a queen
each side just has a knight we've
mentioned before the knight
and the queen they they team up so well
together um the knight is the only piece
which can move in ways that the queen
can't
um white meanwhile is trying to sneak
into the black position with his queen
black just advances his king that's a
bit risky normally we don't want to
advance our king when
the opponent has a queen on the board
but magnus he knows that
knights are a king's best friend his
knight black's knight next to his king
right now
is a great defender um so magnus he's
got no fear here
um also we should mention the bar the
green bar below uh well below me right
now
it is the computer evaluation the
evaluation of the computer the computer
thinks that the position is
roughly level but it's very slightly in
black's favor
that means yes with best play with
perfect play the position should be a
draw
but we've mentioned black is the one
with the long-term advantages
white is the one on the defensive so
maybe he can hold but he'll have to be
very very accurate in the pontiac
yes and uh magnus knight
yes he's moved his knight yes
that's right he's slowly starting to
advance his knight heading towards the
center
another very logical thing to do um a
very sensible move there from
jenna pontiac i think he's just trying
to he's
okay and magnus is doing the same
remember we're talking about those
beautiful squares for the night
both nights are going to go into their
most perfect squares and there will be
octa
knights supported by pawns well someone
should uh
someone should just print out this board
and and give it to your banker so you
can put on the wall
this beautiful beautiful chess game but
it's not just me that's admiring magnus
carlsen's technique
we also have a tweet from mustafa he
says as a die-hard fan
of magnus carlsen i enjoy his way of
cool calm
collected way of playing style the
consistency
on his level of attention is to every
single element
related to chess is impeccable what a
blessed era to be alive
ah yes definitely um and they are making
moves i mean
we are in the era of maybe the greatest
chess player
ever and we know the maybe the greatest
football player ever died
um a few days ago so we are lucky to be
alive
in this era and uh wow what is happening
on the board i see the bar
shifting obviously on the opponent's
side that's right a bit of a
strange move there by magnus carlsen he
just advanced his night two moves ago
but now he has retreated again so he's
actually lost a bit of time he's trying
to trade off white's knight here
in the center of the board black wants
to exchange pieces we mentioned long
term
black is doing great so black wants to
trade off pieces but maybe white has an
opportunity here
maybe white can say i'm not going to let
you trade knights but i will let you
trade queens
and napoli actually he's frowning maybe
he's seen this move he could
zoom his queen all the way at the board
and he's done it and he's done it and
the queen's gonna get traded
queens have been traded now we see white
is the one attacking this pawn cannot be
defended white is about to win a pawn
on the left side of the wood i think
magnus carlsen he just forgot that this
pawn would
would disappear and he's trying to fight
back has he blundered
yes terribly yes just as we were saying
how he he's great at keeping control
he's lost control completely
and we see black he was going for this
central pawn he saw this pawn was not
defended i mentioned it earlier
but if black takes it now his whole left
hand side will disappear
suddenly white will have three against
none those pawns will i mean it's going
to be a pawn race those pawns will run
down the board is magnus now losing this
game
it's a race kaya it's a complete race
because magnus
is a pawn down but you can see he's
using that extra pawn that he has in the
center and he's trying to get them
motoring
and it all will turn on whether he in a
pony actually
can mobilize the pawns on the left-hand
side of the board
if they can get going well then i think
it will be game over for magnus
that's right if we imagine the board
splits into halves
on the right side magnus has a four
versus three advantage but that's very
difficult it's very difficult to create
one
big important pawn um napoli actually he
has a three versus one advantage on the
left side
and that's why now we will see those
pawns starting to advance there we go
white has advanced to pawn on the left
side
right at the corner there white is gonna
try and make use of that three versus
one advantage
it's a bit like sport now it's a bit
like football uh white is
outmatched he's out um he's outnumbering
black on that left side
it's looking difficult for magnus he
just has to hold that right that left
side and hope
that his counter play his that he can
distract his opponent on the
on the right side of the board it's
difficult it's going to be a race as
ivanka mentioned it's going to be
it's going to come down to one move two
moves and the pontiac's time is ticking
definitely is he's turned the position
around he needs to make sure that he's
quick enough now though
they have to navigate with so little
time in the clock only two minutes and
20 seconds
for janna pogniacci now the clock is
ticking but he is in a winning position
can he find the right moves with so
little time on the clock
it's tricky because it all depends on
counting and calculation
and you have to be accurate it's very
difficult to be accurate when you don't
have so much time
on the clock and you're more likely to
play instinctively and perhaps
not work everything out that's right and
although white's position is winning he
does have an extra pawn right now
the problem is if all of the pawns
disappear even if black's knight
disappears
if it ends up with white just having a
king and just having a night that's not
enough material to give checkmate
at the end of the game so he needs to
make sure that either
he gets a pawn to the end of the board
and makes a new queen or
he wins uh the black knight before that
but keeping pawns on the board he needs
to keep pawns in there we see magnus
carson trading off
a set of pawns magnus edging closer to
the draw very slightly
white giving a check now with his knight
black king had to move
we definitely see on the computer that
this is a huge advantage for black but
with a lot more time on the clock can
magnus now
will he actually try to play fast so
that uh janna pogba actually doesn't
have time on his clock
to do the thinking that needs to be done
here yes
i mean he looks that way he also needs
to be very accurate himself
so it's a very fine balance between
playing moves that are very quickly
and playing good moves so okay
napomiacci
moving his knight he's getting ready to
come
in with his king to attack that pawn
that black
pawn in the middle of the board that's
right that's actually a great move if we
pull the
board up um just while magnus is
thinking here white's knight is actually
targeting
both of black's pawns potentially
white's that last move
is very classy move by white uh mundo
publicly playing very accurately so far
this knight is tying down black's king
to protect these pawns
meanwhile white's gonna use his corner
pawn as a distraction that pawn is
actually not far from the end of the
board now
it's got no rival it's gonna race to its
end goal it wants to become a queen
knights also are very bad at stopping
these corner pawns black's knight
is going to struggle to stop this pawn
because it can only stop it from one
side
pawns in the middle are easy to stop for
knights you can stop it from the right
the left the center
but these corner pawns knights are
especially bad against them that is what
white is going to hope for that's what
napoli actually need to rely on to win
this pawn on the left side
wow the race is on and i will also
mention before we take that move that uh
wesley saw and karnakumar have started
playing their second game the first
ended in a draw
they are playing their second we will go
to that later what's happening here
david
it's well it's crazy isn't it the white
king has come
forward to help the knight win that
poor back black horn in the center and
magnus has gone on the counter-attack
he wants to win one of white's pawns on
the left-hand side of the board
that's right and one one of black's
pawns has disappeared here
that pawn in the center has disappeared
magnus carlsen
he needs to just try and get rid of all
of white's remaining pawns white has
four pawns left
black needs to sacrifice his knight for
some of those pawns he needs to trade
off as many as possible
if he can get rid of all of those pawns
even at the cost of his knight it will
be a draw but it's not easy
white still has just enough pawns left
to try and win this one we see the bar
as well there the computer thinks
4.6 advantage that is a winning
advantage for white but
the margin for error is so small one
mistake and that could drop back down to
zero
and under two minutes on the clock for
rihanna pognacci there who is now
thinking about how he can win this game
those
in that race he has to keep his his
nerves calm because what we said
he looks like he does he looks very good
he does he does
because he can't believe his luck he was
first of all grinding
suffering a little bit and now he's
suddenly winning
but uh yes he has to be watchful because
knights are the craftiest pieces
on the board they jump around and they
jump backwards forwards and
go sideways and yeah
as david says if magnus manages to
sacrifice his knight and win both of
those pawns
that is it is going to be a draw that's
right and we see black has captured one
of
uh white's pawns on the left there um i
think white is going to capture a pawn
as well
black's last remaining pawn is about to
disappear from the board very shortly
it's going to be a case of can blacks
okay
not sure about that last move um oh the
computer hates it
yeah that's the that's the thing the one
moves the difference
um between winning and losing the
problem for white now is that black is
going to trade his knight he's going to
sacrifice his knight for white's
remaining porn on the right there the
bottom pawn
oh look at yana pognachi he realizes he
blundered a winning position here
oh no it just isn't his day
it wasn't his day he could have just
taken that pawn last move but he waited
one move he was just too slow he didn't
want to calculate what would happen if
he captured that pawn and so
instead okay it is as you called it
david
the knight has sacrificed itself and now
that king is going to make a b
line for the remaining white pawn
okay and they've agreed to draw anyways
have agreed to draw black's king
unfortunately
unfortunately for napoli actually
black's king is just going to come up
and gobble that pawn now
on the left side once that pawn
disappears white only has a night left
that's not enough material left after
checkmate
napoli actually he had it just one move
he just relaxed too soon
one move was the difference there and
magnus crossing did he actually get
really really lucky there absolutely
yeah
absolutely he'll be furious with himself
because first of all he was
in the driving seat controlling the the
state of play
and then suddenly he let it slip and he
had to defend at this terrible ending
it became worse and worse until it was
absolutely losing and then he got away
with it
one bad move and it ended up a draw
and they are sitting still by the
computers both players and probably
looking at this they both
made big mistakes in this game yeah
that's right magnus carson i think
at one point he just didn't know should
he play for the win or should he play
safe and play for the draw because
he's in the lead today and i think
that's what cost magnus carlsen and
that's what forced him into that mistake
earlier on
napoli actually he spotted his chance he
seized on it
he's so close to the win at the end
there but he just didn't see that black
has sacrificed his knight
and that his remaining pawn would
disappear pomniacci
with a bit more time he would have won
that game and i would
have actually loved uh if we could uh
just look at that
where it all went wrong there by here
from napogniachi you said
he was in the race for the win here to
get that pawn over
the board to be a queen and then somehow
he blundered this
what happened that's right so if we
bring up the board we can see this is
the key position
very close to the end actually only
three or four moves before the end of
the game before the players agreed to
draw
in this position white was too slow he
moved his knight
to try and win this black pawn he had a
couple of options he could have just
taken the spawn
off the board or maybe an even classier
move he could have centralized his king
the main thing is you need to keep this
pawn you need to also keep this pawn
at the moment this pawn will kind of
distract the black knight
and once white wins this last remaining
black pawn which is doomed it will drop
off the board shortly
once that pawn disappears white's other
pawn will race up the board and
black won't be able to stop both of
those two white pawns instead
he made a huge mistake he dropped his
knight forward allowing a knight fork
we call we call these forks a double
attack black gave a check
attacking the white king attacking the
pawn and
he was able to sacrifice his knight for
that remaining pawn and bring his king
closer to the
last remaining pawn unfortunately the
players agreed
i had to agree to draw here because
white's last pawn is dropping off just
one move
one accurate move he would have been
able to keep his last remaining pawn
and he would have been able to win the
game but one move of carelessness
yes one slip yeah and i think actually
we have
yes look at this she has made the move
and there he realizes it was a blunder
i said it i mean he's just having a
really bad day so far
first day of semi-finals and it's just
not working for him so
far sometimes it happens you just have a
bad day at the office but uh okay
he can't focus on those previous two
games
he has to look forward and i'm sure he's
gonna do that
so the the score now is uh one and a
half points for magnus carlsen after two
games
[Music]
has that half a point and if magnus
carlsen wins
the next game the third game then
actually the match of today is over
magnus carlsen will have two and a half
points
and he will be the winner of day one in
the semi-final match
all right well there is another
semi-final match going on all right here
we see the score so magnus carlsen
with that one and a half points he
currently miranda wesley so has only
finished
one game they drew that game so they
have half a point each and they are
right now playing that second game and
we will go
into that game and i'm just looking at
the bar david
i can see it is very significantly over
to
wesley so's side does that mean he is
winning this all-american battle
that's right and i think we saw just a
moment ago as well on nakamura's face he
looked a bit pained he knows that he's
struggling
in this position the first thing i tried
to do in any position is i tried to
count the pawns
count the pieces at the moment it is all
level
but we do notice that black has
weaknesses in the position
if we bring up the board we can see that
what white's plan
will be over the next few moves he's
going to try and get at this pawn
at the moment um he it might be able to
capture this pawn um he hasn't captured
it yet he just centralized his bishop
black has a very weak pawn it's in
white's territory that means
he just can't be defended
black has really taken some risk in
advancing that pawn you can see
hikaru is trying to hold on to that pawn
but like you said i
really love white's position and i
really like the fact
that white has a huge pawn right
in the black enemy camp you can see it
there that's the one
and i love that form when when white has
a pawn like that
that means one thing it means that
you've got to
take space you've got to take as much
space by advancing your pawns by
depositing your pieces
in the enemy camp so yeah like i said
there it controls
two squares in the center david can you
highlight those squares for me
perfect and if white manages to get a
knight in any of those squares well
god goodness me it's going to be so good
and i just
really love wesley's position that's
right if white gets a knight into one of
those two squares that we just
highlighted
i think that will be game over and
actually i like the idea of maybe
advancing white tonight now
slightly towards the black king yeah
black's king if we notice on the right
side there
it has no pieces around to defend it it
there we go white has it
and when you get a knight on that square
i think i think it was kasparov we said
it was worth the pawn
that's right so it's it's so good you
have a lot of advantage
and i just want to bring in the ding
ding ding because
hikaru nakamura has got under five
minutes on his clock and wes is always
about to do it
as well so there will be the time is in
play here the clock is in play
definitely
yup he will be feeling the pressure he
will be looking at that clock and having
to make
quick decisions yeah nakamura is good
enough to realize that he is in trouble
here
he had to tie up his bishops on that
left-hand side just to tie
just to protect that pawn we highlighted
that we pawn a moment ago and
black's bishops now they're offside
they're just not doing anything on the
left
meanwhile white is attacking on the
right i mean this night move is a
beautiful
night uh this is a beautiful leap
forward now attacking the black king
potentially
going to highlight this weak pawn white
queen is also going to use a bit of
teamwork he's going to try and sneak
into the black position
yeah and just look at that bishop as
well that you've got that white house in
the center that could
dominate he could in the right
circumstances be
unleashed into a monster that's right
all of white's piece is doing a great
job black's king needs defenders around
it but at the moment black bishops
they're just doing nothing here on the
left
those bishops just hitting thin air
hitting their own pawns
white pieces they're more centralized
they're coordinating better
this is just um yeah weslito has a huge
advantage right now
yeah absolutely and we have a tweet from
carl portman who says
chess champs some people say that chess
is dead with the advent of computer
chess engines
nonsense never exclude the human factors
the mistakes are all there
waiting to be made a nice quote by
tarzak over there yeah
fantastic and we know hikaru nakamura
he's all about computer chats he
that's about all he plays this computer
chest
and he would be the favorite in this
matchup against wesley so but
was this all looking very good here yeah
that's right
hikaru nakamura i think he was one of
the first um
to really oh no i don't like that last
move but we'll come to the moment
okay yeah yes okay yeah nakamura was one
of the first to learn purely by playing
online i was going to say and he's the
first to really embrace computer chess
people he's kind of a pioneer people
just followed on from him
to play online we have seen the last
position and we see him nodding
what does this mean nakamura yeah it
means that he's slightly more confident
now
and that's because wesley so has
repeated the position he retreated his
knight he didn't need to
um if we just bring things up nakamura
he dropped his bishop back to attack
this night
white could leave it he could just leave
that night he could start going for this
weak pawn that we were talking about why
is he has a huge advantage he's just
going to win a pawn
instead wesley so he retreated his
knight allowing black to
bring the bishop back this the second
time we've seen this position
if the position repeats itself again for
a third time the game is automatically
declared a draw
wesley so let's just hope that he's
feeling brave and he goes for the win
because he has a huge advantage
he's put his night there and now the
bishop will go back and
he has done what you said i had a huge
sigh of relief there because
for a second wesley was playing with us
think telling us that maybe he was going
to go for draw but no
he has realized she has a great position
here okay
yeah he knows that he has a great
position it was just we've seen
wesley be very pragmatic before and just
take draws
in positions where he was winning but
okay
yeah for example yesterday uh wesley so
he went to the armageddon match against
rajabov and he was completely winning he
had an extra rook
but he still took the draw because he
knew that that was enough for him to win
today i'm glad he's playing for the win
though he knows that
he won't get too many chances against
nakamura and he has to take those
chances when they come
nakamura there advancing with his queen
one square
he's aiming at a pawn on the left side
there one of white's unprotected pawns
um but does the computer now think
white is completely winning this that's
right i i think white has actually
several ways to win this position
maybe if we bring up the analysis board
we can talk about white's options
black's last move attacking this pawn is
not defended but that pawn is doing
nothing
black will have to lose a lot of time
with his queen if he wants to go after
that pawn
meanwhile white for example could just
shuffle his rook across two squares
love that move and then you're
threatening because you can't one thing
we have to point out you can't
actually take that pawn now because
there will be a pin the bishop will come
out and you can see those two rooks are
on
the same diagonal so that's not possible
so i love
love love love your move of doubling
along that line
rooks love a bit of teamwork and if you
can double up your rooks if you can put
them on the same line as each other
that is normally a good sign i think
that would be an extremely strong move
here from wesley so yeah
um he's got a bit of extra time i hear
okay now the clocks have equalized the
only thing that can hold him back here
is if he panics
um nakamura can be a scary opponent when
you've only got one minute on your clock
he finds that move he has
doubled up his rooks yeah on the same
line there
um very strong played by wesley so and
you can just see
those two rooks are going to be so
powerful once the line is clear and i
love
love the next move because
but wesley so is not content with being
dominant
on the left-hand side of board he's gone
to the right as well just to over
stretch nakika nakamura that's right
imagine you're being i mean as nakamura
now you're being attacked
from the right attack from the left and
you're worse in the center
of the board everything is going wrong
for him um
we noticed as well as soon as hikaru
brought his bishops to the left side
wesley attacks on the right side and
there's a huge threat in the position
exactly oh okay
so hikari has spotted that that's right
if we bring up the board
just very quickly we can see wesley so
he has a huge threat he just brought his
queen forward he's threatening to move
this night now
he's threatening to give a check to the
black king and more importantly
once he moves that night there would be
a discovered attack attack against the
black queen this queen is not protected
so
black would lose a queen in that
position therefore nakamura he sidesteps
there's no way to give check with the
knight right now
but white has a few winning moves he
could just take this pawn with the queen
or he's he sacrificed the bishop going
for checkmate
he's played bishop takes pawn uh
sacrificing itself if the pawn takes the
bishop there's a few ways to win he can
just sneak into the position with his
queen
queen and knight we've mentioned it in
other games we mentioned it in this one
queen and knight together they're going
to give checkmate such great teamwork
yeah and there's just no way that that
queen the black queen can
hop over to protect her king you know we
have this kind of jokey saying a queen
always protects her man
but here she here the black pieces
cannot do that
because that night is so powerful you
know kasparov said a night on that
square is worth at least the porn and
yeah just look at hikaru
he knows it's over i mean yeah look at
yakara's face he's nodding he's uh
shaking his head and we know he's taking
the bishop and wesley has taken the pawn
and now the king has sidestepped that's
right all wesley needs to do now is
bring one of his rooks into the attack
he's at the moment he's got a queen
attacking he's got a knight attacking
but the rooks aren't helping look at the
black king it has no defenders around it
it just needs one more attacking piece
to overwhelm black's defenses
so at the moment as white i would just
want to bring one of those rooks
towards the black king there's a few
ways of doing it i think wesley he just
needs to be slightly careful
and he needs to play quickly oh yeah
once one of those rooks enters the game
that will be over yes all right well we
we know from the interview with wesley
so yesterday he said he would
not have hikara nakamura's webcam uh up
on his screen he did not want to see
karanakumura because he makes so many
faces and he shakes and he
you can definitely see now he is not
happy with the position for himself
yes he he he knows that he's on his last
legs there's no way going back
and saving this but uh yeah absolutely
david's called
that if wesley manages to get one
of the rooks to stand opposite the black
king
it will be game over there is nothing to
be done
so now yeah he's going to do it the rook
has
moved and it wants to take a little bit
of a long route but i think it's going
to get there
that's right if we bring up the board we
can see the root of this white rook this
rook
it takes a while but this there's just
two moves now if the rook can just jump
up one square and shift itself across
if it can lift itself across this will
get at the black king this will end up
in checkmate
yeah so nakamura he needs to try and
stop this i don't think there's a way to
stop this
um he just doesn't have any protection
around his own king yeah
and you know you can just have a look at
why uh black's extra materials there are
two bishops which are normally really
powerful
but they're on the wrong side of the
board they're on the left-hand side and
there's no way that those two bishops
can
ever go back to help the king so you can
just imagine if the king could talk and
put out a call of distress
not one single piece could answer his
aid
he's trying his best to get rid of the
attacking pieces he's lifted up his rook
he's going to
he's going to take that white knight
next move no matter what pretty much
but i don't think that's going to help
wesley so he can just lift his rook up
again
nakamura he's trying his best but once
that rook joins the action that will be
the end of the game
um we can see nakamura we've talked
about his faces many many times before
he has different faces for different
occasions but once he starts to exhale a
lot breathe out a lot he knows it's all
over
yeah and the rook has moved up and
wesley wow wesley so he doesn't even
capture the black rook last move
i would have taken that rook off i would
have given a check and then taken it
um yeah instead wesley he leaves the
black rook on the board he's going for
checkmate that queen
white queen white's rook they're just
gonna drive up the board and
checkmate is coming black is gonna have
to lose his queen e
just to survive a few more moves i think
this one won't go on too much longer
checkmate is coming yes okay we're going
to see it kaya
and now you will see the chicken
did he react like he didn't see them
just jumps off his chair and in the
all-american semi-final battle between
wesley and hikaru nakamura
wesley so is now in the driver's seat he
is one point up he won the second game
wow that is impressive by wesley against
the online king hikaru nakamura very
impressive by wesley
also he overcame his own demons
sometimes he's his own worst enemy he
takes draws in great positions
but this time no he turned down the
chance to make a draw
and he went for the win very impressive
stuff
all right well david i i think we need
to go it was fast indiana it was
dramatic in the end there can you
actually show us where um wesley got the
win here
sure yes kaya i mean it was so far so
dramatic and it all started from a big
sacrifice
wesley so in this position we talked
about his attacking pieces he has a
queen attack well he's a queen attacking
he has a knight attacking he also has
this bishop
and therefore he decided now is the time
i'm going to ex
break open the defenses of the black
king
gonna destroy that shelter he sacrifices
the bishop for a pawn
that bishop has to be taken now he takes
a pawn with his queen this queen is
going to jump up the board
deliver checkmate very shortly therefore
nakamura he had to stop that he had to
shuffle his king across defend this key
square
all wesley needs now is to bring another
piece
calm move just bringing one of his
pieces into the game for everyone at
home
always do this improve your pieces when
you can and wesley so
just shows his rook across this rook
going to join the attack
and deliver the killing blow and that's
what we see in the game nakamura he
tried to
remove one of white's attackers but that
didn't help he got rid of this knight
wesley said no i don't care i'm just
going to use my queen and my rook
together
this queen this rook they're going to
team up and penetrate the black position
and we saw that um in this position
after white gave a check
remember this check the queen is
defended by the white rook black's king
has to run away
um there's no way to block black or
white gave a check and here nakamura
resigned
because checkmate is coming there's only
one safe square for this king that can
cast a step forward
wesley would give another check with his
rook the rook is again protected by the
queen the king has to step back
one could now give another check rook
and queen
protecting each other at every turn such
great teamwork
giving check to the black king the king
has to step back no matter where it goes
if it goes this way or this way the same
checkmate is coming white will just lift
his rook up to give checkmate
the rook protected by its queen and the
black king can no longer escape
checkmate ends the game that's beautiful
finished it is a
beautiful finish and even that checkmate
even has a name
oh what is it it's called the kill box
it sounds quite venomous doesn't it the
kill box
and we did see hikaru nakamura's
reaction there that was devastating to
him so
all right uh hikaru nakamura uh versus
wesley so wesley so is up
by one point after two games and now we
see magnus carlsen
versus janna pognaci magnus carlsen also
up by one point after two games they are
now
playing the third game and if magnus
carlsen wins this game
then the match first for the first day
it will be over magnus carlsen will be
the winner of day one
if this is a drawer and a pony actually
wins then we will have a fourth
game all right well they have started
david uh what are we seeing on the board
here
that's right so we do see a repeat of
the opening from the first game
we mentioned it a couple of times the
opening is called the grunfeld defense
this normally signifies that black is
happy to let white have the center
but black is going to counter-attack and
we see early on if we bring up the
analysis board black
has brought his queen into the game very
very early
we don't normally want to do this at
home because the queen will get attacked
we saw in this position white has white
has the center white controls the center
therefore black needs to play fast you
can't let your opponent control the
midfield
the center of the board um you need to
counter-attack therefore black gave a
check
this is a check to the king white block
this check
there's three ways of dealing with the
check you either have to run away with
your king
you have to block or you have to capture
the attacking piece um this time
white chose to block attacking the white
queen and the queen
enters the white camp this is very
controversial i've actually studied this
position myself
i prefer white black's queen it looks
very nice in the white camp but later it
will get kicked about it will get
attacked by white's bishop
or it will get attacked by white's rook
um meanwhile black is just hoping that
his
pressure on the center his knight is
attacking this born his bishop is
attacking this pawn
it's all about the fight for the center
right now and also white needs to forget
uh he needs to remember
sorry that his king isn't entirely safe
in the center of the board
if white can get that king to safety and
deal with that pressure on his center
white will be um doing very very well
yes
um all right well jonathan pomnyacci he
needs
to strike back here if he's uh going to
be able to
to fight back in in the semi-final match
day
one and uh well he did uh
how did it end in the quarterfinals he
uh he
he won the first day didn't he no he's
striking back he
lost the first day exactly struck back
on the second day so what happened with
him he's the king of the comebacks
yeah but uh yeah this is but this is
against magnus carlsen
um magnus carlsen is somehow he's the
boss he's the one who kept his call he's
the only one
who went into the quarterfinals with a
lead and actually
got through and did the job yeah but uh
yeah and we did see him thinking
very intensively there like with his
head in his
hands is this still opening preparation
he's
thinking about trying to memorize yeah
this is very much
still opening preparation and now magnus
is the one who has to recall his
preparation and like
um like david said it's all a battle
about the center
white as you can see with those two
pawns in the middle of the board
white will try to reinforce that hold it
and black will do
everything they can to destabilize that
because
if white manages to make the position
completely stable
then black is in big big big trouble
because those pawns control
so many squares so magnus now has to
just remember what he has prepared
i think he's just i think he knows this
is the thing with magnus i've realized
in this tournament
he just lets his opponents wait a little
bit before he understands the thing
exactly before he just bamboozles them
your favorite way of acting i like that
word now to abuse
his opponents all right well actually
we've been talking a lot about
memorizing today
um and you told me i'm very glad to hear
that that chess players aren't
complete robots just remembering
everything they ever saw on a chessboard
uh you actually go into preparations and
then you do the short time
memorizing but what is your best tip for
for
regular people to to to like
get better at memorizing stuff well my
tip would be
to either write things down or to
um use a website such as chessable
which uses the science of space
repetition learning
so where you repeat things again and
again and so this one will identify your
your weaknesses and your advantage your
strengths so if you can't remember this
one line it will force you
to keep playing that one line again and
again and so eventually you'll get it
i mean because i really like that
because chess is all about patterns as
well yeah once you memorize that pattern
those things don't tend to escape you
anymore what
what are your techniques david for
memorizing i completely agree it's all
about practice
whether that's playing through things on
the board i personally learn from the
heat of battle
i like to play games for example on
chess 24 you can go to the play zone you
can play against other
other people other humans the more you
practice against them the more you try
and hone your openings
you'll learn what they normally do
against your openings you'll learn
what the most common uh replies are to
your favorite moves
and that's how i learn that's how i
remember things i always
rather than remember you know what i've
written down i just think oh i had this
game
two years ago against a certain opponent
i just remember that the feeling the in
like the intimacy of that battle um it's
that feeling which really kind of
spurs me on and magnus did remember he
made a move and janet pugnacci answered
uh what uh what's happening on the board
now
we could we think the game is about to
end
actually in a draw yeah um prematurely
with a repetition of moves we're talking
about space repetition to repeating
things to remember
but this time um janna pomniacci he has
the option to
repeat the position for a third time if
he gives a check with his queen
if he just moves his queen two squares
up there giving a check to the white
king along the diagonal
that'll be the third time we reach that
position and the game will be declared a
draw
um napoleon actually he is behind though
normally a draw
against the world champion is great
especially with the black pieces
but this time he needs to think about
the match situation he does need to
think about this match situation
oh magnus is really putting the dilemmas
into it because like does he accept the
draw
and then maybe he takes his chances when
he when napoleon has the white pieces
or does he have to fight
for the initiative right now even with
the black pieces yeah and
personally if i would napoli actually
i'd be looking at the clock situation as
well he has six minutes more
on the clock almost um he's six minutes
more uh magnus carson is clearly a bit
unfamiliar with this exact opening line
with what we've got on the board so i
would be taking all of that into
consideration i would forget
the fact that he's black i would forget
the fact that normally a draw with black
is a great result
i would play for the win it feels like
this is a moment to strike
if he takes it all down to the next game
that's a lot of pressure to put on
himself
he'll have the white pieces yes but
that's not enough to guarantee that
you'll get winning chances against
magnus carlsen
it feels like now is the moment he
shouldn't be thinking that long he
should just play
play a move any move he needs to show
magnus that he's not scared
and play for that win all right so
excited about his next move now
what are we looking for from yana
pognati now
as a sign that he will be fighting i
think
any move apart from moving his queen and
giving check
any other move would mean that he's up
for a fight for example
um if we bring up the board we should
keep on the players though just in case
we see the reactions to a draw
um i would just move my rook towards the
center eyeing up the white queen we've
talked about rooks on open lines this is
what i would do
and there are other moves you could just
develop your bishop just improve a piece
when in doubt improve a piece um just
don't go for that draw napoli actually
because
you might live to regret it all right
we are so excited to see what yana
pognation chooses he
does need a win in either this game or
the next game
if he is going to get back in the first
match in the semifinal against magnus
carlsen
all right and he is thinking that the
time is running
he's drinking a little bit he's
wondering am i going to take this into a
draw and
just fight in the last game or will i do
start the fighting already here
all right let's see what he chooses
that's right and magnus carlsen
he looks a bit confused right now maybe
he thinks the position's already repeat
itself three times
um if we if i just check that um
it looks like the position hasn't been
repeated three times yet magnus carlsen
thinks this should already be a draw
so maybe that's why he's magnus is
looking confused right now
um very tense moment here it feels like
a critical moment in the pomniacci's
tournament
in order to well actually both players
looking confused here i'm wondering if
they're both good just going to go for
the draw and end the game
neither of them look like that magnus he
just reacted there it looked
he looked angry yeah yeah he kind of
shouted at the screen
and we know magnus carlsen hates to play
these draw he wants to fight and fight
and fight and
even if it's good for him that this ends
in a draw if it does
then he's actually trying to shout to
yanaponyachi
come on you fool fight
exactly um i don't really know what
what's happening right now both players
looking confused yes they are maybe he's
shouting at himself maybe shouting at
his opponent
maybe he should have to get the computer
oh i wish we had sound on these players
now
maybe not well yeah
all right what is happening janet
pognashi is still thinking
we are looking out for that queen move
that would
um end up in the draw if you
if he repeats the position one more time
he's still thinking
that's right i mean the only thing i can
really
i think here that magnus is trying to
complain about is the fact maybe he
thinks the position's already repeated
itself three times
but the fact is it hasn't um last time
this position
i mean this is the second time the
position has been retreated last time
his queen was back on its starting
square
the first time maybe he's just been
slightly confused there it can be
confusing trying to count
whether this position's been reached
before um for example world number two
fabiano caruana once tried to claim
against me that the position had
repeated three times but it hadn't he
got slightly confused
about this the placement of one okay and
we have that move
we have a move it is a queen check it's
not the same queen check that we saw
earlier so it's a slightly different
position
but it all depends if magnus carlton
blocks with his bishop
the probably actually he's got to decide
where to put his queen out if he puts it
back from where it came from oh he's
changed his mind he's made a different
move
okay yes we're gonna have so we will
have a fight
yes yes yes all right well yonder
pognati spent a lot of time almost five
minutes
thinking about should i go into this
draw or make a different move
now he does well he actually does have
12 minutes on the clock
that's right i think there was maybe the
players they were both confused i think
the clock just deducted a couple of
minutes yes
okay because they fooled me too all
right well there you see that's probably
why they were shouting the clocks were
not correct uh are they correct now
let's see if they are i think they are
correct now
that's one question for you to ask the
players later yeah what that
kerfuffle confusion was about um
meanwhile black has put his queen on a
different square so we haven't seen the
same position three times the game will
go on
great fighting spirit from the koniacci
guys i have to tell you it does
seem like a chess has captured the
imagination of the world
it is everywhere and we have this
amazing
tweet from the bishop
who says look i can do diagonally
i like a light-squared bishop i can move
diagonally on this floor oh it's
brilliant
that's your kind of humory obviously
totally
oh fantastic i love it when we get
pictures as well fantastic
me too i absolutely i love pictures the
comments the tweets
move suggestions anything you know i and
of course we in the studio are really
loving that and you can join in the
fun and the jokes and the conversation
by tweeting us on this
hashtag chess champs please
do that as we are waiting for magnus
carlson's move
he is under eight minutes now no drama
on the clock yet
um he has been confused probably and
wondering will this go into a draw or
not
now he has to keep fighting in this game
um
is it looking okay for him yes it's
still early days
magnus he does have this pressure we
talked about those two pawns those two
white pawns in the center of the board
one of them is attacked right now by a
black knight by a black bishop by the
queen as well so white has to deal with
that pressure
magnus carson he doesn't look fully
focused right now maybe he thought the
game was about to end
he needs to get back into the game he
needs to refocus
he needs to deal with that attack on his
pawn he also needs to get his king out
of the center of the board white's king
there we see in the middle
he's never going to be safe in the
middle he has to get it there to the
right hand side
he has to castle that king sooner or
later um the pressure is on magnus both
on the board
and the clock i think this opening's
been a bit of a disaster for him
he needs to find accurate moves to put
uh
to kind of put the ball back into
pontiac's court here magnus is
thinking and we had some dramatic
minutes there uh where we were wondering
what was happening and magnus had a
reaction i
let's let's look at that reaction
he he was really angry and we're not
wow yeah something happened
something really upset him and we're not
quite sure what it is
we will definitely try to get an
interview after all the games they have
finished
and ask him about that okay we do have
some moves that's right so white has
actually sacrificed a pawn
we see that one of white's pawns there
on the left side has disappeared from
the board
black's queen is gone on an adventure
she's being greedy she's grabbed a pawn
there
and we see that black actually those
pawns on the left side
black's pawns at the top of the board
they are unrivaled they are unmatched
those pawns later will be a huge factor
trying to rush down the board
in the meantime white is gambling
everything on those central pawns white
has just pushed a pawn in the center
there
attacking the black knight um nice
sacrifice there from magnus i personally
quite like it
but black is now a pawn ahead um napoli
actually an extra pawn and an extra five
minutes on the clock
this is the game for him he needs to
fight he needs to come back in this game
otherwise he might not get another
chance and so far we are still
in territory well known so
the players have played this position
before so they keep playing fast i
actually
all right uh to everyone at home who's
just mesmerized by how fast these
players are able to play
the moves in the openings i actually
asked one of the grandmasters about that
one time
and i was told that it is kind of like
for
for me when i'm memorizing
for example the road from my childhood
home
to my um school i can easily i could
easily walk that
entire road uh without thinking my
feet would just walk the whole way i'd
done it a thousand times
and he's the grandmaster i talked to
said it's kind of like that with the
openings
done it so many times so you know the
moves are just
so easy to find yes there are some lines
where it is
completely like that you've played them
so many times you've been through it on
the computer on a board
hundreds and hundreds of times that if
it does like this and you and it sounds
impressive just to kind of do
20 moves like that but it is very much
like you've played at the hand and knows
what it wants to do
um there are other kind of situations
which are so unusual that
five moves in you're like i don't know
what's happening here
but uh yeah chess is like that there's
the differences and there's the road
well traveled
that's right it's all about muscle
memory in a way sometimes you played
that
you played those exact moves on the
board with your hand so you you can kind
of close your eyes you know exactly what
to do next that's the same for these
players actually
most of them they spend 90 of their time
studying chess on a computer
so they've done those clicks before
they've made those maneuvers before
like their hand kind of carries them
through um i think that's the case for
napoli actually here who's had this
position before but magnus carlsen
may be less familiar he doesn't have
that muscle memory in this exact
position
that's why he's spent so much time and i
can also let you in a secret that even
the
really top grand masters they are
working
on their memory all the time it's not
like they look at it once
and that's it they know everything there
is to know no
no they are there with their teams going
through every single line and there's
the coach going
no you got it wrong do it again and
that's exactly how they're memorizing
and i think i was told that it took
someone
three months to fully memorize one
opening
yeah nothing comes easy in life it's all
about hard work
and uh they are making some moves is
there interesting stuff happening on the
board david
that's right so maybe if we bring up the
analysis board we can explain magnus
carlsen's last move especially
surprises me a bit we see that white's
bishop has just
moved um whoops sorry white bishop has
just moved up the board
two two squares um he wants to support
his central pawn so white
his whole idea is to push in the center
meanwhile we see it's a race
normally we see pawn races in the end
game but here we see a race already
it's getting exciting what black is
pushing and look at the bar
the bar is zooming up in black's
direction this pawn
um this pawn on the left side it's
already only three squares from making a
new queen
meanwhile white is pushing in the center
white pawn is also three squares for
making a new queen
it's a race which pawn is stronger on
the left the pawn on the left flank
or the pawn in the center black retreats
his queen out of the way this pawn this
pawn is nearly running home already
white just pushes his queen forward it's
right it has moved one
step further so this is such an
intriguing battle because one of the
great things about having
a pawn like that on the edge of the
board is that equal
decoy a lot of white's pieces and i just
really like what magnus is doing he's
just
calmly centralizing his rooks
so attacking the queen and he's going
magnus is going to try to use
all his pieces to support the advance of
that his pawn in the center
that's right and i mean this is very
cool very calm from magnus i would be
panicking personally if one of my
opponents pawns down the flank
was so far down the board already so
close to making a new queen
you can see the queen is now supporting
that pawn so that pawn is
really ready to march one square forward
and then make a queen
so magnus has to tread carefully
all right and we see stockfish coming up
here david that means that the computers
move suggestions and
um are these good suggestions by the
computer
that's right so stockfish is one of the
strongest computers out there
just one of the strongest chess playing
entities in existence right now
and it recommends three moves for white
all of those three moves though
actually white's best moves they all
give black an advantage we see that the
evaluation next to it
it says minus one point zero minus one
point one actually napoli actually he's
leaving the room i'm not sure he's not
allowed to do it no you're not he's not
allowed to do that
um what is happening now
jana pogniacci has left the room
regulations clearly state he is not
allowed to
leave the room wow that's controversial
because i mean i'm sure he's not doing
it i'm sure maybe he just needs the
bathroom maybe he needs to cough
but you're not allowed you're not
allowed because unless
there's been some specific dialogue with
an arbiter
then uh then you're not allowed because
some players they do have the
opportunity to go and check a computer
for example you could be checking what
stockfish says and that for these
players that's a huge advantage
that's why we have those rules in place
but because obviously uh the arbiters
the
the referees and a chess game cannot um
control the entire
apartment of jana pognachis
okay i'm very excited to hear what they
will do with this he is not allowed to
to leave the room right unless he has a
camera in the other room just to show
that he is
um i mean there's no funny simply going
to the toilet yep
uh okay we will definitely check out
what's going on with
with that and if he was allowed to do
what he did leaving the room
um it is magnus carlsen in the move
that's right and magnus carson we saw
with the stock fish evaluation magnus
carson is in trouble even his best moves
give black a one point advantage or one
porn advantage
if we count the count the material on
the board as well black is also a porn
up and that's not just any pawn it's a
very dangerous pawn there on the left
flank
um two squares away from yeah promotion
um wow yeah that is very dangerous and
you can imagine if
there's a little body there that comes
and joins in the play
my goodness me yeah it's gonna be a game
over but uh
wow we've got some controversy yes and
and i actually have got
gotten noticed back from the the
technical people um
from chess 24 that that make sure
everything is running okay and
the reason magnus carlsen was so angry
was
that he did what did actually have some
technical issue he closed the browser
when he opened it up
or logged in again it didn't go back to
the position he left
but it was all sorted out so he is
apparently happy now but then we know
why he
had that rage against the computer at
some point during this game
and we do not know what was happening
with y'all nopony actually leaving the
room
um and if he was allowed to do so so we
will we'll check out
check up on that as well it is minus
girls thinking
in a position where he is looking a
little bit worse
yeah on he's looking worse on the board
and also maybe
affected by that disconnection earlier
those internet issues
um his time situation he has only four
minutes
in a bad position there we see he
shuffled his rook across to the corner
his rook has come back from where it
came from his rook started on that
square
but it has to stop the black pawn he's
targeting that pawn right now
it is that black pawn is defended by the
black queen and the black rook behind it
um so white rook is very much doing a
passive job
it's very defensive right now i think
ivanka's right sooner or later we will
see
another black pawn start to race down
the board first he develops a bishop
yeah that's very nicely done the bishop
comes in to
help the game yeah it's looking very
good for black
the problem for white is that there's
just nothing to do your pawns in the
center of the board they look very nice
but as soon as you start advancing them
they'll probably become a weakness
also if we bring up the analysis board
we can see
for example white wants to push these
pawns but if you push them
black will just capture and now you
cannot use your own pawn to recapture
suddenly open up the opponent's pieces
this bishop will capture a rook
a bishop this rook is worth much more
than the bishop right now
it's just hard to find a plan for magnus
carson how do you improve your pieces
how do you deal with this pawn
how'd you deal with you mentioned is
buddy buddy the b pawn here
on the b line um how do you deal with
these two pawns together
black and complete control here and i
will just okay
because there is a lot of drama going on
in this game right now and we do know
that yana pognancy left the room
i will read from the regulations now
that players are not allowed to leave
their desk and camera while
in a game of theirs is in progress and
they do not have the permission from the
arbiter this includes
bathroom breaks there will be regular
breaks in between we know that they have
15 minutes
um it states very clearly they are not
allowed to leave in the only in case of
emergency is the only
only time they are allowed to leave so
we will
try to get clarification um
the only the only reason he would be
allowed to if
if he had agreed with the arbiter that
he was allowed to
that's right i think magnus carson he's
not the kind who would complain about
that he wouldn't launch an appeal it
must have come down to the arbiter's
decision
um once i was playing a game and the
doorbell rang and i was told by the
arbiter everyone could hear me
so i had to go and answer it but i was
penalized i had to lose time on my clock
as a punishment for that so
um i don't think there'll be any issues
here hopefully i'm sure napoli actually
wasn't doing anything dodgy
i'm sure he wasn't doing anything dodgy
but those are the rules
exactly those and you have to you have
to respect them
and i'm sure i mean hopefully he's
communicated to the arbiter that he
needed to leave for whatever reason
and uh the arbiter gave him the go-ahead
and everything is okay but uh
rules are rules or rules i mean there
was a fantastic case uh
of the american player whose bathroom
was leaking
out of his playing chest and he also he
couldn't leave the room either because
he would be penalized
and so he had to message his father and
say hey can you
sort this out and yeah
well rules must be rules because
obviously if a chess player leaves the
room that he
could potentially check the computers
that is what the the world of 2020 is
like computers are everywhere it is easy
to check so
that is why the regulations are so
strict even if absolutely we do not
think any of the players are cheating
yeah and this is actually why we have
these webcams in play
they say that we can see the players and
can make sure that nothing on toward
and also as justine banksy points out we
can enjoy them
she says i love the webcam's best part
of 2020 chess
so yeah that's right and also the
referees the arbiters they have other
webcams
they have cameras um giving a whole view
of that room just to make sure there's
nobody else there just to make sure
there's no other technology
in reach of the players and yeah
personally i agree it's so
interesting seeing their facial
expressions up close normally even at
these big tournaments sometimes
i'll be in the same tournament as magnus
carlton but i can't see his face because
he's so far away he'll be
on the stage it's hard to tell the
reactions so this uh this is a dream
this online chess
um that being said magnus carlsen in big
trouble
in this game um black i think has i mean
probably actually a huge time advantage
and many strong moves in this position
we mentioned that other pawn the buddy
um running down the board i think that
pawn
uh that we see it's at home now it's on
the the b line
um it is gonna start running okay it
doesn't yet napoli actually tries to
trade a pair of rooks
i'm less keen on that one but i think
napoleon actually is still in complete
control
and apparently apparently he was allowed
to leave the room he
had gotten permission from the arbiter
so he is
not in any way um
cheating or not in any way um
disqualified
excellent yes good news excellent good
news because we really don't want to be
losing a game like that
exactly so all right well there has been
so much drama in this game both
chess wise and other things happening
but now they are playing and yana
pognacci
what's happening that's right and black
is offering a trade of queens right now
i think ivanka you didn't like that last
move by white retreating a bishop to the
back line
you don't want to retreat unless there's
a clear reason magnus carson attacking
his opponent's queen we see magnus there
just gesturing against the camera
he's so frustrated right now
everything's turned against him in this
game his internet connection the
position the clock
we see the queens have left the board
black is still a pawn ahead though and
it's an
important pawn it's that pawn on the
left flank that huge
really advanced pawn there for black
that is going to decide the game yeah
white force to retreat another bishop
black's rook now lines itself up with
those two bishops those two white
bishops
under fire from the white uh from the
black rook
black's in complete control we see that
by the bar as well a four-point
advantage here for black
and if it is uh internet problems for
magnus carlsen what are the rules if he
is disconnected
so he has 30 seconds to connect back on
and if he manages to connect
then he will simply lose the time that
it took for him to connect up
and if he had less say say for instance
he had 10 seconds left on the clock and
it took him 20 seconds and he's just
lost one time automatically
but if he's disconnected say in the
middle of the game
and has taken him five minutes to
reconnect then that actually the timer
stops after 30 seconds and
the game pauses and it will recontinue
when he manages to connect all right
well now it is ianna pomnyacci's clock
that is running is he
completely winning this position right
now that's right if we bring up the
board we can see
black has two very strong moves here um
there is a pawn
not protected in the center of the board
black could just zoom up and capture
this pawn
it looks like he's leaving his pawn here
this very advanced this
powerful pawn unprotected the problem is
white's rook cannot move
it is tied down to this bishop um okay
instead napoli actually goes for a
different move
a one that i also like but maybe not
quite as much as just
if you have a free pawn that you can
take and there's no repercussions
there's no
uh there's no consequences i would just
take that off the board instead the
problem actually hitting
um trying to break things open in this
open in the center if white takes this
pawn on offer
suddenly black's bishop will join the
game that would be deadly
that bishop came in and started looking
at that rook oh goodness me
that would be the end of the game that's
right so it makes sense what napomiacci
is doing he's just
slowly undermining white's central pawn
mass he's undermining it from the side
now
strong move look at why it's bishops
just tied down these bishops they're
such
sad pieces they're both very vulnerable
now
white's rook's passively placed just
tied up guarding this black pawn
white's bishop's passively placed
everything's gone wrong for magnus
carson
yeah absolutely everything and it's even
difficult to find a move because i i'm
sitting here wrecking my brains because
you've got to find moves that are tricky
as well
and magnus carlsen has found the best
move i think just to
advance his bishop and attack that all
dangerous pawn on the left-hand side of
the board
that's right and there we see stockfish
evaluations just above the board there
on the top right hand side it does say
that black has two
great moves here black could capture a
pawn with his rook i mentioned that a
moment ago that pawn is still
unprotected in the middle of the board
as black i would just take that pawn off
the board make sure that it doesn't come
back to bite me later
that very far advanced pawn i would
capture that with my rook that could
also that last pawn push he made on the
right side of the board he could also
capture a pawn there so
two different pawn captures both
extremely good but if he doesn't find
either of those two moves
his advantage will mostly disappear
you can just see on magnus carlson's
face he is not
too comfortable he is leading by one
point in the first day semi-final match
against janna pomnyacci and niana
pognati is now very close to
equaling the score and they will if that
happens they will play
a fourth game today it all comes down to
that one
that's right and he's doing the right
thing here he's just he's slowed down
slightly he's taking a pause he knows
he's still got four minute advantage
this is the critical moment as long as
he captures one of the pawns
magnus carlsen's defenses are going to
be broken white is just running out of
uh running out of resources all of his
pawns okay we see a pawn has left the
board
and he's running out of time as well he
is running out of time
and the position is not looking so hot
okay so magnus
has moved his bishop to attack the rook
and
the rook has moved to counter-attack
the bishop that white has on the dark
squares
that's right so the black rook there
attacking white's dark square bishop
um we could see a trade of bishops here
this last move
very clever from magnus uh from
jannapolici it looked like he was about
to
drop some points here drop some material
instead his rook just steps back
counter-attack now two bishops are
looking at each other as well
we've seen magnus carson capture this
pawn
but i think black can just simply trade
bishops on this square and then capture
upon with his other bishop
black's bishops in complete control
black is also going to be a couple of
pawns ahead
um magnus trying to stay in this game
just trying to survive as long as
possible
we saw him save a losing position in the
last game but if napoleon actually is
careful
if he's accurate he's still winning is
this easier for
napolniacci to just get into that win
or is it the same as last time quite
difficult he has to play very accurately
he still has to play accurately because
there are a lot of pieces on the board
but ends
because there are a lot more pawns on
the board then it is easier the margin
for a draw becomes
lower and lower for magnus carlsen um
i would uh definitely say napoleon has
extremely good chances of winning this
no completely agreed he's going to be
two pawns ahead um i think
now is the important moment he needs to
okay he finds it he captures a pawn in
the center with his bishop
white finally removes that far advanced
pawn on the left flank there
but if we count the material left black
is two pawns ahead
two pawns in the end game is normally a
decisive advantage
one pawn sometimes you can hold that
pawn you can blockade that pawn but
black has an extra pawn on both the
right hand side
and the left side black now just
bringing his king into position
his advantage dropping slightly there i
think he had a stronger move
but black is still in charge
all right well the moves are coming out
very fast now
and magnus carlsen is trying his best to
save this
is draw the only thing he can hope for
now that's right that's right yeah
yeah magnus he just doesn't have enough
pieces left to ever win this one unless
the probably actually mouse slips
um unless he just well suffers a
complete disaster
um but he still has drawing chances if
napoleon actually can't get one of those
two extra pawns to the end of it yeah
and i really do like his last practical
decision where he's retreated his bishop
one square
in order to offer the trade of bishops
and i think this is his best chance
because with those bishops gone we'll
get into a rook and pawn ending
and perhaps that pawn on
the right hand side of the board the one
that is closest to the white king that's
a little bit weak because it's not only
doubled but it's unprotected
so black will have to do a lot of uh
degree pokery to try to defend both
those pawns
that's right so ivanka wants to exchange
these bishops
and then the white king will target this
black pawn this pawn
which can't be protected by a fellow
pawn these pawns are actually doubled
um they're on the same line so very good
defensive try there by magnus carson the
problem is going to be this pawn
this pawn is unopposed right now
napoleon actually needs to bank on that
pawn becoming a queen later on that's
going to be his winning
idea um yeah i think the clock situation
as well an opponent she just has to be
careful he doesn't get
very low on the clock because as we saw
in the last game that's what cost him
and he has gone under five and even four
minutes on the clock guyana pongiachi
you have said that is when the clocks
start ringing and it starts to get very
tense
yana pognyachi is thinking about his
next move it is a pawn move
and he has marched that that pawn
forward on the left hand side of the
board it is going to inch ever closer
to making yourself a queen the bishops
have come
off and i do expect white to start
getting i think perhaps i think white
needs to make sure that his
rook is on a more active square at the
moment it's not great he needs to keep
an eye on that
black pawn on the left side there and
normally rooks they belong behind
pawns especially past pawns which have
no rival white should put his rook
behind that pawn now so he should
zoom his rook up to the top and then
shift it across to keep an eye on that
black pawn on the left hand side
um for example in this position
personally i would be moving my rook up
to either this square or this one and
then i would drop my rook behind this
pawn that's the best way to keep it
um okay we see stockfish above the board
agrees
um i think this is the best way to stop
black spawn if you leave it one move
if you move your okay he puts his front
instead his rook is passively placed in
front
we see the engine stockfish doesn't like
that move at all that might be the
losing mistake from magnus carson
his final chance was to put his rook
behind instead of in front of the pawn
in the way that that i didn't approve of
that i was thinking
exactly along the same lines as you
david the rook behind the pawn and now
it's in front because it's passive
because if you're ever going to save an
end game like this when your material
down
it's by having a really good rook
and if your rook is behind was in front
of that pawn well it's not very good
it's not very active and this is
boring that's right and there was a trap
in that position magnus carson couldn't
have taken that pawn
with his rook because if the rooks get
traded off the board
black will win black will win this game
so magnus carson he has to retreat with
his king but once you start retreating
it's never going to go well um black can
slowly improve his pieces
eventually black will bring his king
over to the left side
and use his king to help shepherd that
pawn black's remaining important on the
left there yeah
shepard that pawn forward but at the
moment um
it's just looking like magnus carson he
just has to sit tight and hope that
napoli actually doesn't find a winning
plan
yeah and i will mention that wesley so
and hikara nakamura
they had another draw in their third
game so wesley so is leading
two to one that means hikaru nakamura
must win the last game if he wants to
win the first
semi-final match against wesley so or
else
if if they draw it or whether so wins
then he will be the winner of day one
so we're going to follow all the drama
there as well but we have to finish
off this game and it is looking like
magnus carlsen will lose this game and
that means that
they will equal the score and it's all
down to that last
game absolutely kind of that's what i
think as well
i really love what napolita is doing
he is going to be using teamwork i mean
david said it earlier on teamwork makes
the dream work and that is
that is so super important in an end
game so i fully expect to see
that king the black king start marching
its way to the
left-hand side of the board that's right
black has
only actually one winning plan here
because on the right side
black has a three versus two pawn
advantage but it's very hard to get one
of those pawns down to the end of the
board they're always blocked by white
pawns
on the other side though on the left
flank black does have one
unopposed pawn and it just needs the
king to support it so if we bring the
board up just
i mean uh napoli actually here he's
thinking how best to do this
but he needs to bring his king round to
support this pawn once his king joins
the action
this pawn is going to race down the
board black's king is just needed
it needs to shuffle across to get rid of
the blockade of this white rook
once that happens black should win
can the clock destroy this plan for him
though
he has to find this he has to find these
moves within two and a half
minutes yes the problem with the clock
is that it's constantly ticking
and you don't have time to accurately
count and what you needed to do black
needs to do
is assess okay if i move my king
over to the left left-hand side of the
board and if i lose one pawn
am i gonna be in time and this is the
problem okay
so actually we've seen that happen okay
has made a run for it with the king and
that king is going to be
headed towards the left-hand side of the
board to assist
that pawn in promoting that's right
napoli actually i think he's
he took a while he let his clock drop
down a bit but he
has stumbled across the right plan and
the correct plan and
i think he's going to execute that plan
it's very hard for white to stop that
white needs to create a distraction
white needs to win some pawns now on the
right side white needs
those his own pawns to start running out
the board but white pawns are still at
home they haven't really
started the race black is always going
to be ahead in the pawn racing
magnus carlson there he's fidgeting he
knows he's his time is ticking
and he needs to come up with some tricks
he needs to distract napoleon he needs
to make napoli actually panic
but it's looking it's looking ever more
likely that black is going to take this
point
yeah and and the great thing is that
white still cannot capture
the pawn on the right hand side with a
rook because
of the move rook opposites the rooks can
then
face each other so i think that's right
if we bring up the board we can see
there's a trap in the position as well
as ivanka mentioned it looks like white
can capture a pawn
but this would be a losing move white
would have to resign or give up
immediately
if white captured this pawn with his
rook black could finish the game
immediately by
trading off the rooks this rook is now
pinned we would say white's rook cannot
move because the king is behind it
the rooks would have to leave the board
and once the rooks leave the board black
is a pawn ahead
when you're a pawn ahead in king and
pawn end games you are winning this pawn
is just gonna run home
or distract the white king also if white
had captured the pawn with his king
the same thing would happen black would
drop the rook down and the rooks would
trade
uh be exchanged leaving the board and
black would win therefore
magnus carson doesn't take that pawn he
doesn't fall into the trap he gives a
check
napoli actually tries to trade rooks but
we see
that magnus he he just has to keep the
rooks he has to hope for the best now
i think he just has to pray napoleon
actually defending his pawn with his
rook there
um yeah two extra pawns in rook and and
rook and games is
normally uh enough to win and
magnus retreating with his rook
okay are we going to see
napomniechi's king start to help
its pawn on the left-hand side of the
board
i think napoli actually just needs to
bring his king left he's not rushing yet
he's just advancing his pawns on the
right side
i i think there's no reason not to bring
his king to the left side right now
um that being said he's not rushing
that's a good thing that is a good thing
because there's a little motto which
says hurry
no rush no no hurry don't rush harry
don't rush
harry the h pawn hurry no hurry hurry
but don't rush
because if you rush you can spoil things
yeah and magnus also has
a lot less time now he's got one minute
against two minutes and jana pognacci
also got
going under two minutes right there
i mean this game has been so interesting
it's
we had it all we had it all oh and look
at
stockfish that's right so this might be
a critical moment black actually only
has one move to maintain the advantage
well
to maintain a winning advantage um he
doesn't find it oh
no i'm not liking this move at all
and stockfish doesn't like that move
magnus carson was frowning as well
but magnus carson maybe not finding the
best reply giving the advantage back to
black
um we we saw that white's now white's
rook is shuffling across one square he's
trying to jump up the board and give
check with his rook
he wants to attack the black king but i
think he had a safer option he could
have just
kept that pawn blockaded black's pawns
on the right side now he's advanced them
they look good but they're actually weak
so i think the pontiac's last few moves
the plan
wasn't great he should have rushed his
king over to the left side napoli
actually was winning
yes um still probably winning but he
needs to be ever more careful now he's
letting it slip a bit
yeah no i really agree with you david i
i think something has gone
a little bit wrong with napoleon's
position because that pawn that advanced
on the right hand side of the board
that's weak if the white king goes back
on itself and snaffles it off suddenly
it's white who also has a past pawn in
the equation oh
okay so black has centralized the rook
magnus now under one minute on the clock
yeah and we know
when you when a player goes under one
minute that means
the likelihood of a panic is going to
increase
yeah that's right in napoli actually
okay
actually magnus carson pushes his rook
all up all the way up the board i was
gonna say napoli actually looking calm
just taking a sip of water there
um finally magnus carson we talked about
rooks needing to be behind pawns
magnus he could have done that about 20
moves ago instead he finally corrects
his mistake he's trying to push his rook
behind the black king behind black's
pawns but maybe it's too late now black
is the one
pushing his rook forward to attack
white's pawns we're going to see
magnus carson try to eliminate black's
pawn there on the left flank
i think that's a very good move by
magnus carson the computer says it's a
great move vienna pogbachie is also
under the minute on the clock
that's right actually he's letting this
one slip we said he was so in control
for so long but
again he's used to having loads of time
on his clock now he's dropped under a
minute i think the pressure's getting to
him we saw he raised his eyebrows
he's going after white's pawns on the
right side but he's forgetting that
his most important pawn is that pawn on
the left there
that pawn on the beeline um once that
pawn disappears
oh the computer hates that move the bar
says now it's a draw what's happening oh
look at that and i
look at that magnus doesn't even capture
the pawn instead he gives a little check
to drive the king backwards oh and i
think i think the palmetto has blown it
he has blown at this position um
napolita he will still win one of
white's pawns there white's remaining
poor napoleon actually probably will win
that one
but this position is actually a
well-known draw black will be two pawns
ahead
but those two pawns they're not
connected they're not connected to each
other they're separated
this one it is a draw but white needs to
know what he's doing
all right and magnus is now thinking
and he makes this move is he doing the
right move here that's right he's going
behind with his rook now to try and
check the black king
um finally magnus carson he's got a
position that he will have studied
before i can guarantee magnus carlsen
studied this exact
end game before with black having two
extra pawns but separated pawns
um basically all he needs to do is make
sure those pawns don't advance together
um white is just gonna keep checking the
black king from the side from behind
and they're very they're very dangerous
when those pawns are far advanced up the
board
at the minute one of them is quite far
back
and the second pawn that is in white's
half of the board
is very well guarded by the king and i
know i think magnus has this completely
under control
unbelievable stuff to be honest i i've
said it before today and it's
just not your napoleon to this day
that's right like
looking down everything was in his favor
as well magnus got disconnected magnus
was
flustered he couldn't focus he was just
angry with the position bad
i mean bad situation on the clock bad
situation on the board two pawns down
with a very straightforward plan
as i really i find this quite shocking
that's right
napolita he just forgot that his pride
and joy was this pawn on the left flank
and
he just let it be traded off he's left
himself with two pawns but
white's king will easily deal with those
pawns
um yeah this is very very surprising
stuff and probably actually he will be
able to advance another pawn here we see
him push
upon the problem is now there's just no
way of making progress
he has to give up one pawn to get the
other one running but one pawn in the
rook end game is not enough
here black's rook is paralyzed trapped
in the corner defending his own pawn
yeah rook is passive
this position will end up in a dead
drawn end game
black can't get one of those pawns down
to the end it's close but not close
enough
and and prominently is
thinking is there anything else he can
do here is is
this he cannot he cannot keep that pawn
that the king watches so closely i mean
because he the rook is so passive the
rook needs to mobilize itself
but okay the brook has made license k
and magnus will take off that pawn
and uh now okay so we are going to see
a lovely technique by magnus carlsen so
i suspect that his
rook will now get behind the pawn
looking
he just he looks so sad
like it's just yeah he's had
two excellent shots and uh
he hasn't been able to put the ball in
the net that's right
twice in a row um and we see magnus
castle just repeating the position there
he's going to use his rook to start
checking the black king sooner or later
um this is a very well known draw black
only has one pawn left
and that pawn will not be allowed to
advance the whole way white's just going
to keep giving checks
um sometimes he can even offer to trade
rooks white now because one pawn on its
own
isn't enough so an opponent is trying
hard by advancing this king
but notice how magnus carlsen is using
his
king and his rook to stop that pawn
advancing
remember in endgames it is david
howell's favorite expression
teamwork makes a dream work and you have
to remember that
that's right and both whites rook and
and king covering the same square
covering the pawn advance napoli
actually they're just shuffling his rook
across that move actually doesn't do
anything it's a waiting move
and now the rook ha the white rook has
come to gobble up the white pawn
and we are going to see i think the
players agree
a very quick draw that's right napoleon
you can tell on his face yeah he knows
it's over he's laughing to himself
he's missed another opportunity second
game in a row
he had it in the bag just nerves the
clock everything just made him
yeah absolutely absolutely i think he
was so
he was trying to maximize his position
he won he knew the plan
but he just wanted to improve absolutely
everything before the king made his dash
to the left-hand side of the board and i
think that was that was basically
his failing he pushed too hard
yeah i said it in the match against
anushkiri magnus don't get him in the
end game he knows all the tricks he's a
magician
he will escape somehow by hook or by
crook and another
piece of escapism and escape act there
from magnus carlsen
impressive defense and how is yana
pognacci feeling now
another game he is winning and then just
not able to to
get it the ball in the net as you said
yeah i mean i i can probably
yes i can even verbalize we say man come
on
yeah break no i mean he's he's
he's devastated he knows there were two
points that
up for grabs and he didn't do it he
bottle it
you feeling sorry for him david yeah
i've been there myself when you're
dominating the whole game it's like
ivanka said sometimes you control the
game you get all the chances you get so
many shots you just can't get that ball
in the net
i've been there especially against these
top players in the world sometimes you
can
outmaneuver them you can outplay them in
the early stages sometimes you can even
control the middle of the game
but in the end game they always have
tricks they always make you work for it
you have to win the game a hundred times
just to get one point it's
so difficult and probably actually two
games in a row now
yeah no two games well i would say he
was the victim of himself you know he
was the one who took the bad decisions
and he will be kicking himself so much
yeah um okay one more game left to play
yeah he can
still pull it back he's been so close
perhaps their time lucky
all right well let's look at the
standings both semi-finals are done with
three games so it is magnus carlsen with
two points against jana pognyacci's
one point and that means that if magnus
carlsen is able to
draw this last game he will be the
winner of day one
if janupomniacci wins it then they will
have a draw in their first semi-final
match
and is all to play for tomorrow so for
hikaru nakamura and wesley so we know
wesley so won that second game
and he is like magnus carlsen up by one
point against tikar nakamura i mean
sikhar nakamura needs to win that last
game that will start very soon
um if uh wesley's always able to draw
that game or win it he will be the
winner of
day one so much drama going into
the very last round of the first days of
semifinals and um
david um this game for this last last
game it had it all we said it so many
times magnus carlsen and janet pognyacci
there was a disconnection problems um
just didn't go the way for for either
player but
it was iana pognyacci pushing for the
win where did it go wrong for him
that's right we were i mean we were
always certain he was winning this game
that's right he was so close so many
times even towards the end
i mean earlier he had i mean countless
chances to put the ball in the back of
the net to finish
this one off but i think the critical
moment came down
very near the end he started pushing a
pawn on the right side of the board
he didn't need to worry about that you
shouldn't push pawns unless
i mean they can't just they can't go
backwards you shouldn't put pawns unless
you're sure it's for the right reason
and he just created
his own weaknesses he pushed a pawn here
when the plan should have been simple we
mentioned this ivanko mentioned this
just walk your king over use your king
to push this pawn forward
to guide it home king pawn and rook
together
i mean this pawn is destined to become a
queen white would have to give up his
rook for that pawn eventually
um black would remain a rook up black
would win this game
instead he over complicated things he
gave himself these weaknesses
he pushed his pawn down the board and
suddenly suddenly this pawn is a
weakness
he i think the final mistake though was
trying to go after white's pawns on the
right-hand side
again it's not too late this pawn is
still your strength he let that pawn
disappear
he went after the wrong pawns he went up
to the wrong plan
and in this final position um we see
that unfortunately
um just a few moves later these two
pawns on their own they are not
connected they don't protect each other
and it's just not enough to win magnus
carson showing his end game quality
showing he's done his research in end
games before his study
and easily drawing this game missed
opportunity
and look at janna pogniacci as he
realizes he
blundered a winning position again
and the great thing is we've got to
repeat yes yes
yes oh he is just so
unhappy with himself not being able to
oh just
get that ball in the net for the second
game
in a row and now they have 15 minutes
before that final game
magnus carlsen only needs the draw jana
pogba she needs a win
what is he going to do in that game well
that this is
this is the question so he has to reset
desperately because
he will be fuming but okay emotion is
too much in this game he
really needs to just get there and just
play a game of chess anything
all right well we actually did see in in
this last game magnus carlsen had some
internet connection problems and well
super hard question we asked the chess
players again what would they rather
have
really really bad internet or really bad
[Music]
relationships
this is heartbreaking but okay don't you
take bad internet what you got to do
i need a good internet i actually would
be hap very happy
to not use internet ever again for the
rest of my life
you lose a lot of time you lose your
mind you stop thinking
yeah living without internet is
difficult but possible oh no internet is
very important
okay bad internet i hope that we will
return to open the ball
chess soon yeah i think i'd prefer the
bad relationship with the good internet
to be fair
oh bad internet because i already have
it
already bad internet in india for read
it ah
ivanka what would you choose bad
internet okay
well we know your husband is watching
david how about you uh
my internet's pretty bad my love life's
pretty bad as well
at this point all right we actually also
have simon williams joining us ginger gm
and i'll ask you you too simon what
would you rather have
really really bad internet or really bad
relationships
oh that's such a nice easy question to
start me off with right
um i'm gonna have to say bad internet
right so yeah
we'll start easy all right i've been
loving your show today by the way it's
been
fascinating fascinating day chess thank
you so much simon and
we will also mention to all the viewers
that simon is doing his own stream
ginger gm stream on twitch going
maybe more in depth into these games and
analysis simon
uh yeah that's right i'm streaming like
live every day on twitch
and we're going into details we're
having a look at the other games as well
uh very interesting um so there's so
much chess now out there
it's a very exciting time for us chess
players and lovers of the game
so yeah and what is your favorite move
of the day and maybe
also david can be really quick on his
computer and find that move
what i have to say one of my favorite
ideas i think it was
occurred in the other game between
wesley so and the h-bomb
hikaru nakamura and it was i think it
was in game two
and we can bring this up it's on the
37th move
and wesley won this game so he had the
white pieces and he came up with
a nice little concept to bring all of
his pieces into the battle
i've heard david talking about how it's
teamwork
and you can see this position here with
the black king
looking very naked it's really
embarrassing himself he's put some
clothes on that king it's getting very
breezy over there
but at the moment there's no obvious way
to check mate the king the knight and
the queen
are kind of hovering around it ready to
sting it like a bee
but you need to bring in some
reinforcements and this is where white
played
a lovely little idea he went rook e2
and this is what i call the rook swinger
one of my favorite maneuvers and then
this rook
came up the board and it swung itself
around
to attack the black king and when that
third piece entered the attack there was
nothing
that hikaru could do to defend so this
was a really nice maneuver just bringing
in all the pieces
to the attack so yeah great stuff great
stuff
and we know that wesley so is in the
lead in that matchup against hikaru
nakamura
they just started playing their final
day of the game of today
who's your favorite to win day one now
simon we know that hikaru nakamura can
be
fierce in comebacks yeah i mean hikari
is probably
one of the guys who you could bet on to
always come
back he's got such a strong mentality
about him
but wesley so is a very calm player and
hikaru is going to have to do something
particularly special to bounce back
today he's possible it's possible he can
do that
but i'm still going to go for wesley so
in that game
and and what do you think about magnus
carlsen and diana pomnyacci
we're just feeling so sorry for your
napoleon it's
just not his day here i mean chess chess
is like a cruel mistress it's really
quite harsh at times and
um i think like magnus carson i mean
he's such
an escape artist i mean you put him in
alcatraz he'd be out within 24 hours you
know
he would just find a way to get out of
trouble he really is he's just so
he's so amazing especially in the ending
so um
nepo's had lots of chances he hasn't
quite used them there's only one game to
go and it seems like luck
is on magnus's side so again i'm going
to go magnus with that one
do you agree with him david yes i think
napoli actually he's had more chances
than most people get against magnus in a
lifetime
and he just hasn't managed to finish
them off and i'm not sure he'll get
another one
what do you think you are going i
totally agree with the guys i think
nepal nietzsche is in big trouble all
right napoleon we see his reaction again
what do you think of that simon that
just disbelief
i i really love watching uh nepo yan
i just think he's got he's such a great
character you can you know he doesn't
hide his emotions you can
blatantly see it on his face and it was
the same with uh
magnus in that game they were both
showing so much drama
uh just with their facial expressions
and you could just watch him i could
just mute it
and you can see what's going on in the
game you'd be like okay wow what's going
on here
so um i i really am a fan of both the
players and
what they give to the game so yeah great
stuff and we actually saw
i'm noticing i i like all the details
that leon has brought
his white regular cup and a yellow cup a
mug to the game today
what is your bet what is in those mugs
simon
um a bit of vodka in one but it gets a
bit dodgy and maybe a nice cup of tea
no of course these guys don't drink that
i mean i guess it's just two different
kinds of drinks and
he's keeping himself well well stopped
up probably why the toilet gate incident
actually happened as well you know which
i i saw
yes we did the check with the arbiters
and he was allowed to do that
they had checked that off and well
actually magnus carlsen in a podcast
earlier this year said that uh during
one of the world championship matches
or maybe it wasn't world champion it was
the rapid or blitz championship
he actually got drunk because he was
playing so bad
i mean could that be a solution for you
on the ponyo chair to just
have some vodka and just forget
everything
i think i think that's something you do
after the match it's quite a risky
strategy
doing it during the match it could make
very entertaining viewing though i mean
i would
i would definitely tune into that but
probably only for us not for him
to watch that so uh yeah i mean maybe
not encourageable at the moment
all right um simon thank you uh so much
for joining us
again and we will save that bear in that
vodka for for after today's chess
um good luck with the rest of uh your
streaming today
thank you very much and well done guys
good luck and i'll see you again
tomorrow
see you again tomorrow thank you so much
simon yes so
you can watch the simon williams ginger
gm stream on twitch he is going more in
depth
into the analysis um and we are getting
ready for that last game of the day for
ian fognachie and magnus carlson um
do you think ian pumiacci can actually
shake off everything that happened today
and just get into fight mode now i think
he needs to
um he just needs to reset whether as you
mentioned whether taking a swig of
alcohol it's just that way to completely
um just start afresh or
maybe he'll just be trying to play
something a bit different
to what he normally does just to try and
get himself in the zone he needs to just
forget
that's the main thing forget it's a new
game one chance
to come back and max he can just come
to the board and and play a draw here
quite comfortably but he never does that
does he
yeah but he has a very solid repertoire
so he knows how to make things tight and
he
understands napoleon well very well and
i agree with
both of you you and the probably
actually really needs to refocus and
reset
and uh i'm not sure about the click hole
there's a kind of theory that if you get
drunk you can play great attacking chess
not so good everything else so you can
get very brave probably yeah you get
very brave you get very reckless but
then
things get things get a bit ropey
because you can't quite
figure out what's the best pawn
structure how am i going to maneuver my
pieces that's too complicated
well but it is actually true magnus
carlsen did say that in a podcast
earlier this year that
after a horrible day or during a
horrible day of chess during
world blitz and chess championship he
actually did go to his room and
took all the vodka he could find in that
room and he played
great the rest of the day yeah i've been
there myself sometimes
it's a great form breaker if you're in
terrible form you just need something
just anything
to snap yourself out of it just to
pretend that the tournament hasn't
started
just to start afresh and likewise if
you're in good form then stay away from
the alcohol stay away from anything that
can
ruin your good mood that can ruin your
great health and
yeah i think um maybe he was saying that
tongue-in-cheek but
maybe that might be the trick for
napolita well either way
twitter is incredibly impressed with
carlson's ability
we have a we have a tweet from toria
svensson who says carlson's ability to
save
lost positions is unbelievable just
incredible and i have to take off my
house to pack magnus because that was
just
wow i had written him off and we often
think about magnus as this attacking
player because he wins many games but
also defensively um he must be great
yeah that's right he definitely trains
every part of his game he's always had
those defensive skills ever since i've
known him as uh when we were extremely
young he's always had those defensive
skills his attacking skills though he's
improved them so much
his tactics he calculates he sees deeper
than his opponents
um okay we see him shaking himself off
there yeah he's getting ready
yeah he knows he hasn't been at his best
but oh and we see a smile from
janupomiyachi
okay well maybe well he is ready
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna think about
what he's been doing in his break
oh he does have some key in front of him
very good he's
staying off the alcohol and they're
playing what's happening that's right so
both sides pushing their pawns in front
of their kings on the first turn
one of the most classic openings we go
into an opening it's called the berlin
wall
um and it's called the berlin wall
because black's position is so
hard to break down it's so solid um i'm
very surprised napoli actually is even
allowing this he's going for it because
the berlin wall magnus carlsen he's one
of the leading experts
i think he could often he could draw
this position in his sleep he could hold
this position
napoli actually though maybe he knows
his chances passed he hasn't gone for
the most aggressive attempt
but he's hoping beyond hope that somehow
magnus castle maybe relaxes too early
um i don't like the opening choice from
napoli actually going into this berlin
wall i think he's just going to
run up against that wall and fail to
break it down
magnus carson meanwhile just advancing
his night there attacking white's porn
in the center of the board
this is very traditional stuff i've
actually
i've actually played this position
myself while sitting next to magnus
carlsen
and he said he liked the way that i
played the game so maybe he'll try and
copy some of my ideas
from a couple of years do you have the
black pieces yeah i use this as black i
use this opening when i'm happy to make
a draw
with white white okay white has a tiny
advantage but it's not enough normally
lots of pieces get traded early on in
the game
this is not the most ambitious start
from the pontiac
i'm very surprised in a must-win
situation he's allowing such a solid
defense for magnus carson
maybe he's in the kind of realm of let
it be just
just play a game and see how it pans out
and just to
abandon any attempt at uh putting in any
effort
that's right but this has all been
worked out this position
okay napoli actually very surprised by
magnus carson's last move there
actually the last time i had this ex i
okay apart from that last move i had
this exact position as white
the last time i had it i was playing
against a computer i was playing against
um some of you may have heard it at home
an artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence program called
alpha zero um
you'll have heard of it ivanko i would
have heard of that i'm seriously
impressed you you played
alpha zero the neural network
machine i think something yeah didn't
alpha zero learn chess
in just minutes or something like this
yeah it learned
i mean in within four hours it uh
learned just by playing against itself
and it was already able to beat
stockfish and we've mentioned stockfish
is the strongest man-made
human computer and alpha zero just by
teaching itself
four hours later was able to beat well
just be the strongest chess playing
um entity in the world and i did get a
chance i was part of a team
it was just a bit of an experiment i got
to play against alpha zero this
artificial intelligence program and i
use this opening as white to make a joke
so um with white you use this opening to
try and make a draw
so it's that's why it shocks me so much
that napoli actually has
entered this line yeah surprising times
yeah so the position is pretty like i'm
thinking in terms of the pawns it's
pretty symmetrical
the both sides have four pawns in nearly
the same formation as each other and
okay the pieces are being traded off
that's uh the more pieces that get
traded off the more worried i get from
the publicity because
one of the things you do not want is you
do not want simple positions where your
opponent
it's easy for your opponent to make a
move you need to create some choice you
need to create some complexity
and uh slightly concerned that the
position is becoming
very simple and it will be easy for
magnus carlsen to handle that's right if
we pull up the analysis board we can see
what your anchor means
already we've seen a pair of knights
leave the board a pair of bishops the
dark
square bishops have both left the board
and now with this last move magnus
carlsen offering this queen trade
the queens are looking at each other uh
janna pomnechi says no
no queen trades for you but more
important than even the queen trade
is the fact that the pawns are
completely symmetrical for example if
magnus carson pushes his pawn now
look at the okay he does this look at
those pawns all of black's pawns
exactly um they're exactly copying the
white structure that means there's no
chance to open up more lines there's no
way to unbalance things
just the fact normally symmetrical pawn
structures like this
mean the composition is completely level
um i
don't think that neanderthal would get
anywhere near to any winning chances
here
um white did just attack this night
um this knight was just defended by a
pawn it's also defended by the bishop so
very solid stuff from magnus carson
i don't think he has anything to
complain about here so he's
basically already accepting that he is
losing
the day one semi-final match and just
going all
in on day two it's getting close to that
stage already
all right well with white pieces could
he have
done this differently yes i think he
could have played a different
he didn't have to allow the berlin he
could have played it different he could
have
certainly challenged magnus a little bit
more and certainly
not gotten a position where the pawn
structure is so
symmetrical because again this is what
you want black has
no problems in terms of pawn structure
and also has no problems in terms of the
pieces
you see the rooks are nicely connected
the bishop is defending the knight
this seems to be just a lovely harmony
for both sides
but it still means that a position is
easy
that's right normally especially at this
level in order to win a game of chess
you need
some action happening you see some open
lines or you need for example you need a
bishop in exchange for your opponent's
knight
here both sides have exactly the same
material exactly the same pawns
white has just pushed his rook up the
board in the middle there so that's some
action
some varies very small action um that
rook will just get kicked away sooner or
later
black will use a pawn to kick that rook
back okay um and there we see it there
we see it
okay so still will we see some fireworks
now um
i maybe we'll see some fireworks or more
likely i think we'll see that rook just
retreat
itself yup it's retreated to the second
square so
what is getting ready to line up the
rook on the left hand side of the board
next to it so i agree with you i think
this is gonna see
will it be a quick draw or will it will
they try to play this out a little bit
i think they'll try to play they will
try to play it out but this kind of
chess is like very
it's like the vacuum cleaner has come on
the board
[Laughter]
everything's going to disappear yeah i
wish that i wish that vacuum cleaner
come to
come to my apartment as well now after
five days
six days of chess it's uh well the
apartment hasn't gotten much
attention i have to say that's right and
um
there we see black's last move he is
attacking the white queen with his
knight
i'm a bit surprised by that last
decision by magnus carson
we see the queens have left the board
though and although the bar
the green bar below the two players it's
slightly zoomed over to white side
but i don't think that's enough i think
the fact that all the pieces they're
being hoovered up by that vacuum
i think all the pieces are disappearing
just that fact alone means that napoli
actually he won't have enough pieces
left at the end
to try and create some yes winning
chances i i agree with that david i can
see
some trades happening and then the
knight will simply retreat and there's
just no way for white to penetrate the
position
what really i mean i'm really worried
about these minor pieces
the knight and the bishop are on the
board they they don't have any posts
they don't have anything so i just can't
see a way forward because you always
have to be thinking in terms of progress
you mean you can't just play chess to
stay at a standstill
you have to look at ways to move forward
and uh i'm curious about the pause
though what is he
what is nephromyocyte thinking that's
right i'm surprised napoleon she's
thinking here maybe he's just regretting
his uh his game choices his life choices
i don't know maybe he's just thinking
about the last game where he was so
close to winning nearly every move was
winning
apart from what he did and okay he can
capture the black rook now
either with the white rook or with the
white bishop um one of those has to
capture the black rook
but it won't change anything black will
just retreat his knight from the edge of
the board bring it back into the game
and well judging by his face he could
actually be thinking
why did i choose chess why am i not
doing something else we've all been
there yeah yeah yeah
yeah i try not to think like that when
i'm thinking it's always a good idea
to to play chess we've been thinking
talking a lot about memory
today and i know there's a lot of
studies saying that
uh playing chess is great brain health
really
um avoiding um diseases like alzheimer's
and stuff like that
so it's also always a good idea to play
chess yes it's always a good idea to
play chess yeah just enjoy the game okay
so we see a flurry of moves
the bishop did in fact take the rook and
uh nompromniacci is trying to make
progress
by advancing his king aside
pawns that's right so white just slowly
gaining some space there that
last pawn push we see there with the
green arrow just slowly gaining
control over some territory but there's
just too many pawns left there's not
enough pieces left
um this one i think magnus carson he'll
be looking for a way to trade off those
last set of rooks he'll be looking for a
way of maybe trading the bishops the
knights
um yeah there's just not enough open
lines here for white to get into the
enemy camp
the pawn's still very symmetrical white
does have a set of doubled pawns
on that line in front of the white king
but those double pawns aren't weaknesses
they all protect each other
magnus advancing on the left now yeah
the chances are disappearing move by
move
for napoli actually also the clock
situation magnus carson has more time
than he started with
um he apology won't be able to put
pressure on the clock this game
yeah abs absolutely just a very
symmetrical position and i expect that
the rooks will be traded off very
shortly
um i mean i think the thing is though
you need to keep the rooks
on the board if you're going to make any
attempt at winning this
okay and he has advanced the pawn on the
left-hand side
i really like this this type of move is
uh
a david howell type of move because that
pawn
no no no no no no no no no no because i
noticed something about david
david likes to control his opponent's
knights with his pawns
so then there he is so the black knight
was threatening to
jump into a square on the left-hand side
of the board in the white camp
event at one stage and uh white has just
prevented any idea like that
and that's uh what i've noticed about
your kind of play oh wow
i didn't know about myself i'm honored
do you think that your anchor
um and yeah if we bring up the board
just to show what your banker means
white's last move
just pushing this pull forward one
square black's knight is
slightly uh constricted now it cannot
jump forward because it's controlled by
a pawn
you cannot jump forward to this square
either it's controlled by a pawn and
likewise
it's controlled by a lot of pawns right
now so white is constricting that knight
also white might try to advance a pawn
of his own
so it's still very very much symmetrical
um not too much happening but white is
slowly trying to gain a bit of territory
maybe
um yeah still very much in the balance
though
all right well magnus carlsen is
thinking he just went
under 15 minutes which was the time he
started with so he
he seems uh very comfortable in this
position um so far
yeah and i think he'll just be wondering
how he can end this game as quickly as
possible the tension that emotional
tension
he just wants to get it done and over
and focus just on one day tomorrow
uh focus on stopping the prominently
from coming back so
magnus he'll want this game to be over
the longer it goes on maybe this
the more he'll get nervous yeah possibly
and we have seen i mean
we have seen so many times we've been
quite certain that this is a drawer this
is a win
and then they they blunder all the time
these time controls i love it well this
is the thing which has the spectator
sees
everything exactly it's so easy to sit
here
it's not happening like yeah why are no
sacrifices
yeah if we were sitting on the board we
would be making the same mistakes or
worse mistakes than they make
or playing better or playing better and
we did talk uh yesterday about heart
rates
as well and i guess that also come into
play when when your pulse
is rising and your heart is racing and
uh
it's harder to to maybe control your
emotions and and make the right decision
definitely i think it's human nature as
soon as you see the clock drop below one
minute your heart automatically starts
pumping and
it's just hard to fully focus on the
board fully focus on being objective and
calm
and having that composure to look for
the best move so
yes i mean when your clock drops to less
than a minute
either the thought process goes like
this my clock
it's actually a rhythm to it and before
you have it before you know
50 seconds has passed and you know you
haven't come up with a move
and then you go oh maybe that's how we
burn the calories looking left and right
it's not even the finger moves the mouse
movements it's just the looking
my clock the board my club the board
that song will be stuck to my brain
we should all do it okay one two three
my clock
the board my clock the board my clock
the board okay
let's get back to the board yes
you did it the wrong way too damn it
sorry
you're better at chess than music okay
agreed
um better stress than most things but we
have seen a set of pawns leave the board
um we have seen a trade on the right
hand side there
fair trade pawn for porn but the
position isn't completely symmetrical
anymore
um if we bring up the board just to see
what's happened magnus carlsen he did
try to open up the position he's trying
to force the mata he's trying to end the
game as quickly as possible by making a
draw
so you push the pawn forward these pawns
left the board but
i don't like that decision the pawn this
pawn is doubled we mentioned that on the
same line
he white the black is helping white to
remove a double pawn
and after the capture white moves his
rook across maybe he wants to push this
pawn forward
we've seen a couple more moves that
pushes on the right hand side
white improves his bishop still not so
much going on we
that's reflected in the bar in the
middle there 0.0 okay 0.2
it's not a huge amount happening no i
agree there really isn't so much and
there's no progress being made
made the only thing that i can see and
it's in favor of the black side and it's
many many minutes but basically it's
that
the pawn on the right hand side of the
board
could potentially one day
in a pipe dream make itself into an
outside passport
that's right if we yeah
it very needs a lot of assistance that's
right so ivanka
thinks that maybe you know in
in magnus's wildest fantasies this pawn
might run down the board
it's a long shot this pawn will be
stopped by an enemy pawn
but i like i like the idea it's good to
dream that's my
that's the hope yeah yeah the dreaming h
pawn harry the h-bond
yeah yes this pawn on the h line
it doesn't have an opponent so there's a
small chance that might happen
um but i think napoleon actually will
stop it before it gets there
yes that's why i said it was like
one percent chance maybe yeah all right
well we know that janna pognancy has to
win this game if he wants to
equal the first semi-final day match if
it is a draw or minus wins the magnus
will win
day one that's right and actually we
have seen a trade white has
exchanged his own bishop for black's
knight another fair trade they're both
they're worth roughly the same right now
um the bishop in the night white moves
his knight forward
um maybe gonna uh take that black bishop
the more trades that happen we've
mentioned it a few times the more trades
that happen
the closer we're edging towards the draw
magnus pushing a pawn on the left side
there
white could capture it it looks like
white would win a pawn
but black's rook will whizz across to
the end and start to take those pawns
i don't think it's normally not a good
idea to take
away from the center with your pawns
yeah
i don't think that's going to imbalance
things too much right now
and if they finish this quite soon um it
will be a very early day for
for both players the earliest they've
had so so far in the scaling open and
they will have a lot of time to
for to prepare for tomorrow yes they
will have a lot of time to prepare and
they perhaps will have a lot of time to
think about
what happened okay so probably not a
good idea what went wrong
well especially for yonder pogba then
you said it so many times it's sometimes
just about forgetting
everything it absolutely is but it's
easier said than done okay so porn has
advanced and so we see a flurry of
trades that's right a few pawns have
left the board now
that left-hand side is all just starting
to disappear
um ivanka mentioned it the vacuum
cleaner result
just hovering up all those pawns um yeah
we will see janna pomnechi magnus is
just taken up on napoli actually will
capture that pawn back he's got three
options now
that last porn move by black can be
captured by a knight
a pawn or a rook um i don't think
there's a right or wrong answer here
all of them make sense for white neither
i think none of them unfortunately will
kind of create
enough um imbalance for magnus carlsen
or napolniacci
to really hope for a win here magnus
remember anish giri made this mistake a
few times he traded off the queens
early in the game um what he shouldn't
have done um the pony actually he found
out in that last game he was completely
winning but the queens were off the
board magnus is an endgame
genius an endgame expert uh it looks
like another case of magnus being in
full control
the pontiac will need to come back
tomorrow i think he will
be down one point um after today's
matches
well that's what he did in the
quarterfinals he did make a comeback he
was
fantastic on day two all right we have a
move two moves
so the black rook has gone to the
left-hand side of the board and is now
looking at an open line so this is this
is relatively good news but there's so
few
pieces on the board that it's very
difficult to see it kind of
actually transferring itself into
something material which would be like
an extra pawn
that's right if we bring up the board we
see magnus he kind of has a threat here
it's not a huge threat
just a small one but he's doing the
right thing rooks need these open lines
he wants to jump down and attack the
white king rooks are so
great at covering lots of territory in
one move that rook is gonna
wing up the board um that rook's gonna
maybe give check to the
white king therefore white tries to
distract black he's pushing a pawn
forward he's offering more trades
blacks can give check to the black uh
blacks can give check to the white king
right now
but it is just one check more pawns are
going to disappear soon that vacuum
cleaner is
gaining speeds right now skating speed
is covering more ground
we will see a trade of pawns in the
center here and
yeah the game is fizzling out napoleon
actually starting to come to terms with
that
yeah who who is it that will offer the
draw here
basically and we know they can't offer a
draw until 40 moves but they are
uh just two moves away from that that's
right i think um
in terms there's an etiquette in chess
there's kind of a code of honor
where the player who is trying to win on
the play who needs to win
is the one who should offer the draw
magnus carson maybe if he offered the
draw it might be a bit
not disrespectful but it just might be a
bit presumptuous thinking okay
i know this is a draw but i'm a head so
napoli actually
the bonus is on him i think to make that
draw offer especially with white
especially in the must-win situation
it's him
um i think magnus will wait until
napoleon actually offers
yeah an online chess is also very
difficult to kind of
offer a draw yeah do they have a button
yeah you have to find a button and
sometimes that's a bit of a
difficult perhaps a distraction
and so you're just like okay well if
they want to draw we'll we'll repeat the
position three times
oh yeah because that's usually what
we've seen here repetition of moves
okay well we will pay attention to that
it's it's not happening
yet no that's right and actually magnus
carson is the one maybe playing for the
win he's the only one with winning
chances here we see black's king
is very active black's king on the
left-hand side there it's actually made
a journey
across the board targeting one of
white's pawns and that's why white has
retreated his knight to defend his own
pawn on the left side there
so yeah i agree with you david that was
absolutely brilliant you know the king
has made a brilliant jet but it took a
step backwards that's right i was
surprised by that
step backwards by the black king the
king was beautifully placed
i think black could also have just taken
white's pawn on the left side there
just to get rid of one last attacking
force and napoleon actually remember if
he's only left with a knight or if he's
only left with the king the game is
immediately a draw
um yeah perhaps magnus is trying to be
sneaky perhaps
i dare i say it he wants to win this
i'm thinking i'm thinking he said he's
put all his pieces on the left-hand side
of the board and he's perhaps dreaming
that if he wins white's
only pawn on that side then he can push
that pawn all the way
that's right so um maybe this pawn will
drop
white's pawn is very weak here only
defended by this knight
um whereas it is attacked by the black
bishop right now maybe he'll use his
rook to try and attack that pawn as well
and as your vanco mentioned if this pawn
disappears black will be left with an
unrivalled very very dangerous past pawn
pawn will have well a clear run at goal
really a clear run to the end of the
board
when it might become a queen so some
small chances for magnus carson napoli
actually
won't let it get that far but i agree
black is maybe the only one who can win
yeah absolutely you know it's uh ianna
pomney
who has to make the decision how is he
going to handle that
and the thing is that there is some
cycle the danger
on the board might not be that great but
the psychological danger could be
like the could be greater than the
actual threat so
white has pushed the pawn forward
um that's a interesting choice there
that's right if we bring the board up we
can see white's idea um that pawn push
it does anchor a square so white is now
threatening to give a check
to the black king that pawn protects
this square um
instead i think we will see that magnus
carson maybe just snaps this pawn off
the board
and it looks like a pawn sacrifice for
white but it's just a trade
um we have seen that happen white's just
going to capture this remaining black
pawn
um everything's disappearing the whole
left hand side
all the pawns have been obliterated and
two pawns versus two pawns on the same
side of the board
is just a dead draw neither side can
make progress there
neither side can get their pawn to the
end of the board uh this one
i think the knight and bishop balance
each other out the rooks balance each
other out
yeah the only the only thing that i can
see is that the black king has been
caught on the wrong side of the board it
would be a lot more comfortable
if it were on the right hand side
looking at its own pawns but magnus
has it under control in fact he is now
attacking
the white knight where can that knight
go to it has to move
it has to be all the way back to the
edge tonight
will be forced to retreat that night is
almost trapped right now we saw in the
first game between these guys
magnus trapping napoleon's knight in the
center of the board this time though the
knight
does retreat it is very safe there we
don't like our knights on the edge of
the board knights are very bad at the
edge of the board they can only cover
four squares compared to the normal
eight squares
but um on this occasion we will see
another
set of pawns leave the board most likely
and the game the last game between
wesley sony car and nakamura it did
end in a draw and that means ladies and
gentlemen that wesley so little bit
surprisingly is the winner
of day one in that all-american matchup
and it means
hikara nakamura he needs to make a huge
comeback tomorrow if he wants to go
to the big final all right well we are
trying to get a hold of either of these
players to get a comment
uh but we will also of course follow the
end of this game even if we are
quite sure it will end in a draw yeah
and i think it might end in a draw very
soon we've passed that magical move 40.
actually the players have agreed to draw
oh they have
um all of the pawns were about to
disappear from that right side of the
board neither side has enough pieces
left to win the game
um a fair result in this game but
napoleon actually will
he'll rue all those missed chances he
had earlier in the match
yeah absolutely it really is going to be
a big regret because
if he had put those two points in the
net
then he would be in the lead and he
would have been
winning this match but as it is he has
to make a tremendous comeback tomorrow
yeah magnus carson he's got this i mean
this is a champion's mentality to win
when you're not at your best
it's like winning dirty i think he
called it it's when you're struggling
you can't find your form but you still
find a way by hook or by crook um he's
so good at doing that it shows
you don't need to be your best all the
time you just need to find a way you
need to find your opponent's weakness
and
he seemed to find it he found napoli
actually just unable to finish him off
all right well wow we ended quite early
today
all the all the four games in the
semi-final has ended
and it has ended with wesley so being
the winner of the all-american battle
with hikaru nakamura
he's leading one nil after day one and
also magnus carlsen
is the winner of the battle between
himself and the russian ian nepomnyachi
so that me and sikhar nakamura and yana
pomnyacci needs to make
huge comebacks tomorrow and we know
they're capable we've seen it in the
quarterfinals yeah we saw it we saw the
drama happen in the quarterfinals so we
saw some brilliant games from
nepomniacci
um has been done before against magnus
magnus has
taken the first match and then lost a
second and match has been decided on tie
breaks
so magnus isn't himself it magnus
by himself isn't invulnerable he can
be beaten and uh yeah it's up to
inappropriate
and we actually do have wesley so
joining us congratulations on winning
day one wesley wow
fantastic hello everyone yeah good to
see you again
good to see you too um what was this day
like we know hikaru is
fears online but you just got the upper
hand on him
yeah thank you i feel like it's uh
simply not hikaru's day and i feel very
good today i
felt like i played better than the last
two days
uh so i feel very good today uh
but at the same time i think he ever
played sub par today
so i'm sure tomorrow he'll he'll play
two times harder
uh so i'm going to have a sleep last
night
yeah i'm sure he'll be back tomorrow i'm
sure he'll play much better
but today's just not his day yeah so in
the quarterfinals you went into day two
knowing that you you had to come back
you had to be team
rajabo tomorrow you will will be the
leader when you go into that day how
will you attack it
uh yeah yeah definitely it's a good
feeling to be the lead to be in the lead
but every match is different
um so we'll see a tomorrow try to
play solidly of course mean four draws
is more than enough
so try to start to not
run into any problems with the black
pieces especially in the opening
and uh hopefully be able to be able to
hang on
but but uh i mean if i'm if i played
like i did today i'm pretty confident
but uh
we'll see i've had bad days and i
haven't i've had good days also
wesley um david do you have a question
for wesley
i do so wesley you won one game today
you drew three
in the game you won you had an
opportunity to repeat the position three
times but you went for glory you went
for the win
were you ever tempted to bail out and
take the draw or did you always
have that win in mind yeah good question
david
good to see you again uh well actually i
hickory and i made
a lot of draws also in the preliminaries
and uh but uh but in
in the match format someone has to win
right so someone has to
push through we can't uh make all the
ross
but at the same time i thought my
position had
no risk uh at that stage i
had a pretty pretty good advantage at
that point he messed up in the opening
by playing c5 so uh
i thought there's a possibility that i
could mess it up but
uh when when you give me attacking
chances i feel like
i just have to have to go for it so when
he gave me a piece sacrifice on f6 i
didn't even think twice yeah we saw the
game
we thought it was a very beautiful
finish so well done
well done thank you and when we talked
to you yesterday we know you were
heading out for a thanksgiving
uh dinner to have some leftovers maybe
what will the rest of the day look like
for you now
we know it's uh not too late in in
minnesota where you are playing
yeah it's only two in the afternoon here
it's very early uh
i don't know i i try not to do too much
chess work during during tournament
sorry
yeah you need to keep your energy for
the games uh
so i'll just try to relax uh watch watch
some videos so
watch the watch the news and uh just try
to
start to clear my brain clear my mind i
feel very
very good today which is not what i can
say for the other days
so i'll try to be in the same form as uh
as as tomorrow okay perfect wesley good
luck tomorrow thank you so much for
joining us
and um we actually have also hikaru
nakamura
joining in hi hikaru hey how's it going
hi thank you so glad you're joining us
good to be here thank you um what was
today like
um after you got that loss against
wesley we were we were quite surprised
because we know you are
the online king yeah well i mean i
i basically decided to to change lines i
didn't play the same thing that i played
against
magnus and maxime in previous games and
wesley played
i mean i thought a very principled
approach which i hadn't looked at and i
got a pretty bad position
uh right away so i mean it was just a
bad position out of the opening and then
um
i mean yeah i don't think wesley was as
precise as he could have been but
nonetheless uh
he played he played some good moves and
that's that um
as far as the other games go i thought
they were all pretty um
pretty pretty dry i mean i thought the
final game actually it was very close to
winning for me but unfortunately it was
by one move
i can't checkmate him on the h file so
it was a little bit unfortunate but it's
it's only one day so
you know we play play again tomorrow so
hikaru will you be taking inspiration
from yesterday we saw you had this
really dramatic day this comeback it
must have been a real roller coaster for
you
how did it feel yesterday and will that
inspire you for tomorrow's games
um well you know i think there's there's
a significant difference in the matches
because in the match against maxime when
i lost on the first day i very easily i
think could have won
on the first day as well i was winning
both the white games um
and i had many opportunities where today
i mean it didn't really feel like i had
that many opportunities maybe the last
game was the only chance where i felt
that maybe i had some winning
possibilities so i think the the whole
general layout is a lot different but
but certainly um uh coming back the way
i did there
you know some of the other events like
yance dinger against dubov and some of
the other
uh other finals or semi-finals um i'll
draw inspiration but you know you just
come back
play and um luckily it's the best of two
and not a best of one or
something like that so uh it's a new day
and
how do you relax between the games how
do you pump yourself up or is it just
about
um meditation relaxing getting yourself
in the right frame of mind
um i think mainly just being the right
frame of mind i think at this point the
tournament we've all played a lot of
games so
it's we've all looked at a lot of our
our preparation before and i don't think
there's really a need to um
to review it so i think for the most
part it's it's just relaxing for those
to 10 to 15 minutes and then um yeah
just playing again but i will say i do
like um
the fact that the brakes are pretty
short because for me usually i'll go use
the restroom grab some coffee or water
and i'm already like five minutes are
gone so it's you know you're ready to
play the next game i think certainly
when things aren't going well you always
are ready to play the next game and so i
like the fact that the brakes aren't
super long
and hikara i have to say we are loving
seeing your web camera all the emotion
that you bring to the games
are you triggered by this format and as
you said short
breaks between the games and have to do
a comeback tomorrow
it looks like you're enjoying yourself
yeah i mean i
i i'm definitely not triggered that's
for sure um
but but yeah i think i mean i i like the
format actually i think i think the fact
that there's always something going on
there are always their games going
especially from the perspective of the
fans makes this very exciting um and as
far as tomorrow i mean i just try to
play play good chess and see what
happens and
if i play good chess i think there will
be opportunities um and whether i can
capitalize on them or not is really the
question but
you know we'll see all right hikari
thank you
so much for joining us and good luck
tomorrow we're looking forward to
seeing if you can do that come back
great thanks see you guys
see ya all right that was yukari
nakamura and right away we have world
champion magnus carlsen joining us
after he won day one against janna
pognati congratulations magnus
can you hear us magnus
hey magnus carlsen can you hear us
it looks well we see his camera i don't
know if
he can hear us
oh we can hear him yeah we can hear him
all right we will try again to get a
hold of magnus carlsen
uh in the meantime we can react to what
hikaru nakamura said
uh so great to hear his reaction he and
he seems ready for day two already
yes he does he seems quite pumped up and
i really like the fact that
he gets motivated by the shortness of
the rounds and he just wants to get back
in the ring
and get fighting again and yeah the
format seems to suit him
and it's impossible david to write him
off even if he lost day one he can
always make that comeback day two
exactly he's like the ultimate fighter
on the chessboard
and i have so much respect he was so
philosophical about that defeat i mean
normally we see him
emotional at the board but he's able to
compartmentalize that able to push it
aside
and focus on playing his best chess i
can't wait for tomorrow i know i can't
wait for tomorrow either and
i think now we have magnus carlson
joining us hi magnus can you hear us
yes i can hear you now perfect
congratulations on winning day one of
the semi-finals
thank you uh it was uh quite similar to
the first day of the match with uh
danish actually
um the only difference is then i won the
um the first game uh instead of the
the last game but the other games were
pretty similar and that i was
mainly mainly struggling
um it it seemed like a roller coaster
day and and jana pognati he was
fighting for winds many times we were
commentating on that in the studio
he didn't quite get that did you feel
comfortable the entire day or has it
been
nerves coming into the picture for you
as well
no um i felt good in the in the last
game i didn't
think there was any danger there but
uh i wouldn't say i was very comfortable
especially in the third games i i really
messed that up pretty pretty bad uh
early on
um the second game obviously i had a i
had a very nice position and i
it should never have gotten to to where
it was but
once it got there obviously was no never
never comfortable so magnus you
mentioned that third game and we saw you
on the camera as well
um we heard you had some internet
problems can you talk us through what
happened and whether that affected you
on the board
uh so um
what happened is that the browser closed
for
no reason that i could discern
so it just all closed and uh
was you got quite angry
i yeah i couldn't couldn't look back in
and i didn't understand why
so that's i i mean i i could see
i could see myself losing a game there
on disconnect and
i i i really don't understand what would
happen there because i think in
general my my internet was fine
we actually did see a piece where you
answer that
in the choice between really bad
relationships and really bad internet
you would
choose bad uh relationships we all know
how
annoying really bad internet is and uh
minus
how will you attack day two again um
being in the lead here before that
decisive day
um i guess i'll try to
yeah um to prepare better in the
in the openings um as you could see uh
in the first game
um was well prepared and then
he made a mistake early on and i won one
quite easily
um but in the others especially in the
third game i didn't really
get what i i want so i'll i'll have to
cook up something
something new there but uh overall like
i i'm pretty happy to have uh i've
survived and
uh i feel like in in this in this um
in this match it's like if you can
survive your
your worst day you're probably going to
be defined overall
all right well magnus we're looking
forward to see what you bring to the
table
tomorrow good luck for day two of
semifinals
thank you thank you for joining us all
right so the world champion
like he was in the quarterfinal he is in
the lead before uh
semi-finals he did seem quite
tired after this day ivanka yeah because
it was kind of emotionally grueling
exactly
you know because i'm sure he was a bit
annoyed after the second game which he
spoke
very good position and then how to fight
for his life and then game three was
just everything went wrong but then he
held it
just seemed like you know ian and
napolitani was jinxed
what are your expectations david for
yesterday's
match-up between jan and pogba and
magnus carlson yeah
so hard to predict what will happen
tomorrow i think today tonight magnus
will just be relieved
um napoli actually i think it might come
down to whether he dwells on today
and the events of today or whether he's
able to turn over a new leaf and get
fighting tomorrow
i think magnus carlsen needs to up his
game in order to keep the lead well we
can actually check with janna pognachi
because he is joining us hi john how are
you doing
uh well worse than it should be but uh
i think uh i i gonna do it
i can't believe the rollercoaster day
you've been through and
so many chances and just ah so close to
doing great stuff what has this day been
like
well i kind of
feel relief right now because in the
first game i returned the favor from the
i mean at some point returned the favor
from the group stage when magnus uh
mixed up the the square for for his
queen so
actually i think queen b8 is a little
bit weird compared to queen c7 but uh i
would i would like to squeeze the
seminar board not queen b8
but uh this doesn't really matter
because i mean okay quick queen b8 is
clearly losing
because of d6 yeah but uh it doesn't
really matter because
uh after that after that i had like uh
i think uh two very good chances uh to
call it uh
mildly so i think it's uh about
making you you you know making some
good decisions in the very end uh of the
game and you know as
i think last year said that is the most
difficulty chess is to win a winning
position
so that's uh that's something i i surely
need to master
before tomorrow's match so i'm curious
what did you tell yourself after your
first game how did you get back to the
game and just
fight off the second and then well i
wasn't yeah well
of course i wasn't happy but uh i mean
it happened so clearly queen bh is not a
move i wanted to see a divorce so in
fact it's
it's not like queen c8 you know so
quincy it would be more picturesque
perhaps but you know the result is more
or less the same yeah so i mean of
course queen c7
funny enough i believe we checked this
line together in 2014
together with magnus yeah like was a
small piece of uh a small piece of work
i don't even remember when but i i
i remember well we we had some i don't
know i had no discussion about this
position
and now it appeared at the board yeah
that's
that was funny well john you did a great
comeback in the quarterfinal
against um lavon ironian will you take
inspiration for that from that and
and go in with the same fighting spirit
tomorrow
well clearly i'm uh not so let's say i'm
not so happy with my play today
i mean okay the game too was uh not that
great and
uh i think i mixed up things in the
opening and okay game one is okay it's
it's hard to comment on it and well
actually
i think uh we both played uh
far below our level and magnus during uh
let's say the
the whole game but when he was good in a
defensive part
and well i managed to compensate this
with awful uh conversion
uh so well i i don't i don't need i need
some extra energy extra
motivation for i come back anyway this
is best of two
so one one image you may lose but second
you you get all in here so that's uh the
rules are very simple
all right yeah i actually noticed in the
background there you have your christmas
stockings up already are you already
decorating for christmas
well uh you know this year you need some
extra extra joy yeah some
extra you know i like to call it
christmas spirit yeah so
just to get some good emotions because
there is not so not so much fun this
year we
you know we can have around here all
right yeah we're looking so much to see
your fighting spirit
uh fighting for that comeback tomorrow
good luck
thank you thank you so much for joining
us john fournier
um yeah decorating for christmas already
fantastic i'm getting in here
i liked his attitude it was easy calm
easy go
you know i really expected him to be
quite moody
angry and saying oh you know he was
missed but no he was just laughing it
off and you know
nice touch with magnus playing
they started together and he did
actually explain a little bit david
about
what happened today yeah so i think it
all just came down to that first game
and as we see on the board jan he
mentioned this queen move
so he mentioned his queen over to the
left hand side of the board this was the
big mistake
he said at least it wasn't as bad as the
mouse slip
he could have dropped his queen just one
square where it would have been taken by
a bishop
um so it wasn't that bad but it was
pretty bad he moved his queen over
he said he regretted this is the small
difference at the top level he regretted
not moving his queen forward one square
just diagonally
this gives black a great position
because now his knight will never be
trapped and i can always drop back and
be defended by the queen
instead a couple of moves later his
knight was trapped in the middle of the
board
he said he'd discussed this with magnus
carson before this exact
opening i mean imagine the mind games
that's the
yeah the psychology someone's used
something against you where you know
you've
discussed it before um yeah this we
talked about christmas this was a bit of
a christmas gift
for magnus carlson or even birthday gift
because magnus's birthday is coming up
that's
right that's right but no more gifts
tomorrow i think from yeah nope
and this move was very decisive for
janna pognachi
he ended up losing the first day of
semifinals again magnus carlsen
and i think we can look at what has
happened today so magnus carlsen
won day one of semi-finals against janna
pognati two and a half points
against the one and a half points and
wesley saw
won day one against hikaru nakamura now
these points will
just uh leave us for tomorrow we start
with
zero points tomorrow when they play the
second
semi-final match so we know that yana
pognacci has to win tomorrow to go to
tie breaks
and so does hikaru nakamura he has to
win those
four matches or those he has to win that
match containing of four games
if he wants to take it to tie breaks and
if you get tie breaks we know what that
means that means
time trouble exactly we're gonna slash
the time
and things are gonna get heated up and
we're gonna be have two
blitz games and if this result is still
tied oh my god we are gonna have the
best thing in the world
exactly armageddon where david will have
to smoke a
mouthwatering yeah armageddon chess
white will have five minutes black has
four minutes but white has to win a draw
is not enough
we saw some armageddon games yesterday
armageddon means the end of the world
one of these players is going to be the
end of the world but we're going to love
the drama
we are going to love the drama so much
happening tomorrow as well as
the second day of semi-finals uh uh
our played uh with these four excellent
players we will remind you that it is
still black friday
so if you want to go and get your tour
pass half price off
on champions chester.com do that and you
can vote back one of the eight players
that was eliminated
eliminated in the preliminaries back in
for the next
tournament all right but first we have
to finish off this tournament
and tomorrow we have second day of
semi-finals so please join us back
for the drama that will be happening and
thank you so much for joining us today
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you